with author shelby foote
[Music]
born in greenville mississippi
shelbyfoot's first novel tournament was
published in 1949 when he was 33 years
old
he published four other novels in the
1950s
in the spring of 1954 bennett surf of
random house
asked him to write a brief account of
the civil war for the 100th anniversary
of that conflict
20 years later in the spring of 1974 he
completed the civil war a narrative
containing over a million words the
trilogy has sold hundreds of thousands
of copies
from his home in memphis tennessee our
guest for three hours today on in depth
is novelist and historian shelby foote
shelby when did you move into this house
and how much of your civil war writings
were done from here
uh all three volumes were written in
memphis
we lived down on the bluff overlooking
the river for the first volume
it was moved out to what was then the
eastern city limit i wrote the second
volume then we moved back to midpoint
right in the middle of memphis so for
the third volume how many years have you
lived here
we've been in this house since uh 66 so
do the arithmetic
how much and then
what room are we standing in and how
much of
the house plays in how you write and how
you think
very much so it always has
i've never been able to write away from
home my desk is where i do my work and i
don't write while i'm traveling anything
else i have great admiration for writers
like d.h lawrence and john keats who
could write it anytime anywhere
but i could never do that always if i
take off two days it'll take me four
days to get back to work and i have to
be at my own desk it's a laming thing
where are we in your house well this is
a sitting room with john in my work room
here the bedroom's on beyond it too you
know most of us got to know you in 1990
or thereabouts when ken burns did a
civil war
uh epic of 11 episodes where were those
interviews done they were done on this
couch here uh sitting right here in this
room
what did that what impacted that whole
series have on your life
a tremendous impact
i had not realized the enormous power of
of television until that time
not only to sell books but
[Music]
people think you've been in their homes
they will call you up call you by your
first name and said it was very nice to
have you in that house last week it's
kind of strange and it's somewhat
startling yeah we're going to chat for
three hours our audience going to get
involved in about a half hour with their
phone calls and the emails but for
someone who just might be happening on
this program never seen you before right
how much in your life have you written
you mean how long have i been writing i
know how many you know how many words
how many books uh the civil war is a
million and a half words and the rest of
my writing is about
about that same amount so i've written
something over two million words how
many books total
now there are six novels in the three
volumes of the civil war
and then recently some things i've been
doing for the modern library like uh
the long essay on chekhov and other
stephen crane
favorites of mine
we opened up by saying you're from
greenville mississippi how many years do
you live in mississippi i lived in
mississippi until i moved here except
for school in the army i was always in
greenville for the first 40 years of my
life what impact did mississippi have on
you uh
a great impact
uh one thing that happened i know
everybody thinks they had either the
worst possible childhood or the best
possible childhood
i was raised in a town in the
mississippi delta greenville and uh
it was a population then of about 15 000
which meant that every child in that
town between the ages of say 13 and
and 17
was in that school so you live the rest
of your lives with people you'd been to
school with during an impressionable
time of your life and i got to know
every type of person it could be
and a town that size
one of your best friends can be the son
of the president of the bank the other
best friend can be
the son of
[Music]
almost any anything
and it uh it gets you to know it's sort
of like the army in that regard you get
to know all kinds of people and know
them well just a short distance where
you can get on the bridge and drive to
arkansas how far away from mississippi
uh mississippi is about uh
14 miles south of here
memphis is the capital of mississippi
delta you know it's outside it i found
something on the web that i wanted to
share with you um
this was from i'm not going to give a
student's name because it might be a tad
bit embarrassing but it was a
student i believe from austin peace
state university in tennessee have you
heard have you heard about this no and
she wrote an introduction in a biography
about you
but the last line of the opening says
foot
is a tremendous writer who served in the
civil war and his writings come from his
personal experiences
i'm i'm glad she got that impression
that's the impression i wanted to but
i'm in that book you see i mean i hope
and uh
that's the way i think history should be
written as if you were living in that
time
it's totally unfair to look at it from
150 or years later and pass judgment on
what those people did without knowing
what their values were and what the laws
were even
it's what uh causes an awful lot of
misunderstanding trying to apply uh
apply a different set of standards to a
different
to a different nation really
all right you have how many books do you
think in this house and i know you've
got a bunch back here just want to ask
you what's on the list all the books up
this way books is way books that way uh
i'd be guessing if i said around 8 000
books perhaps what's on that shelf it's
one of your favorites
well i i have a particular reason for
having a favorite they're all my
favorites uh but
up on the next top shelf there
there's a
leather bound
that's the new york edition of henry
james
it belonged to walker percy
uh on the right over there
on the third shelf from the top
is the limited edition club shakespeare
that was my favorite possession
and the james was perhaps walker's
favorite impression and about 20 years
ago we got to talking
and we agreed that whichever one of us
died first
he would leave walker would leave me to
james or i would leave him to
shakespeare
and uh
he lost
the contest
and i wanted uh
that's that's walkers james said he that
he while he was on his deathbed he told
his wife to make sure i got it how many
years ago did walker percy died he died
in 1990
and that's shakespeare over there have
you read all that
oh many times i guess yeah shakespeare
you can't read too much shakespeare why
because the beauty of the language and
the skill with which he handles it
the language itself shakespeare
he's on the moon
when you get to talking about art
in writing shakespeare is outside any
calculations and then music it's mozart
and you put those two people off to
themselves and then you talk about
various other people but uh
they hung the moon we're going to go on
your next room in here what is it
i'm sorry that room what do you what's
that remember that's where i do my work
that's that's my work room it always has
been ever since we moved in i had the
desk built in the bookshelves built in
since 1967. yeah 66. let's go in and see
what we can find in here go ahead
now when you were writing uh did you
sleep in this room
uh seldom sometimes when i was very
anxious to
to to get to it all get up in a hurry
and i was working hard i would sleep in
here mostly stuff right now before we
talk about anything right on this bed
is your life behind you
it's very strange to see it laid out
like that i've never seen it that way
before
i get the impression i somehow managed
to swallow a cannonball
so it's very strange to see it all
together there what's the first one over
here the merchant of bristol this is the
first thing i ever published uh
a friend of mine at the newspaper in
greenville was
random type machine so he he did that
for me i bought the paper that people
put it together
and it's signed and numbered there were
i think 260 copies and i charged a
dollar and a half a piece for them and
the whole town was furious that i could
put such a high price on such a junky
little thing
it's worth a good deal of money now now
tournament was your first novel that's
my first novel when did you start it
when did you finish it i started it um
the first two years at chapel hill i
decided i'd had enough college and it
was time for me to come home because i
knew the war was coming this is like 38
or 9
and uh i came home
and while i was waiting i joined the
mississippi national guard and while i
was waiting for us to be mobilized i
wrote 201
and i sent it to will percy's publisher
kanov
and they read it and wrote to me and
said they liked it very much but they
didn't think it would sell
and i would do best to go and write my
next novel
and they'd be happy to see that but they
thought this would give me a bad name
with book book sellers
so i put it away in a draw
when i came back from the war five years
later
i i got it out
and revised it and
set it off and it was published by
by dial press and the main message in
the book
it's the study of
how each of us is alone in this world
and it's a study of a man's rise
and fall
without his being able to answer that
question
uh
check out they say of him uh he was not
interested in the answers questions he
was interested in stating the question
well
i feel the same way about it how alone
do you think you've been in your life
i
i
i it's hard to say
i i i don't know how to put time things
how do you mean though well i mean you
say each man is alone i mean do you feel
alone
i think that each of us is alone uh
[Music]
being alone is is something that your
prize island to be alone
is is a good thing
but
breaking out of it is something else we
we are alone in strange times uh
you you're most alone during nausea for
instance
you're also most alone perhaps you're an
orgasm
uh this loneliness thing is
a thing can go on forever
the little islands of of quiet in the
middle of the racket of a noise uh it's
um
it's a very strange business when you
start examining
uh
how each man is alone and just a few
months ago you had about with cancer
right colon cancer
what was that like
you take medical things as they come and
you leave it up to the doctors to do
something about it and you do what the
doctor says
i've had all kinds of medical things
since i turned 65
lord lord i've had the stance installed
i had one of the first
balloon bypass or heart things and each
one of those came along and you just
take it as that's what that's the hand
you drew at that time and you leave it
up to the doctor
and thank god i've had real good doctors
where i wouldn't be here i wouldn't be
here if they hadn't developed medicine
as far as they have in the last 20 years
now you're going to be 85 in november
right
what's it feel like to be that age
compared to when you started that first
novel i i can't associate myself with
anybody 85 years old it amazes me in the
first place you're still right
yeah of course i'll stop when they let
me down
but uh nearly all my friends are dead
my closest friend walker pricey has been
dead for 11 years it's hard to believe
it
but
that's where it goes you take it as it
comes and you hope
with some form of grace and you're
married to gwen who's here today how
long have you been married to her be 45
years in september what's that been like
i
can't believe i can't imagine being
married to anyone for 45 years or or
it's just it's amazing right the one
thing that i want you to talk about
because we've talked about it before in
interviews is what's over here on this
shelf yeah uh talking about time
i remembered some things past that the
marcel proust
and right here is the
most is uh my favorite 20th century
writer i i've
ever since my mother gave me this full
volume proof
for my 17th birthday
and uh
every time i feel i've earned the right
to do it i quit everything and reread
bruce i've done it in the back of this
one i wrote each time
as the ninth reading in 1993 i haven't
felt justified and taken off too much
since ninety three so you've written
you've read this book these and this
what three thousand pages
yeah
nine times right
this is right reading
it's uh
two reasons one is pure
pure enjoyment
uh proust is one of the most entrancing
writers that ever lived and the second
he can teach you something you can
always learn a writer can learn from
proof
uh and he can indeed we talk about
shakespeare earlier
that's the grand master teacher let me
stand over here so folks can i see you
better um
what is it about the written word that's
either attractive to people or it
separates it from television
i really think that uh the written word
is what defines us as uh superior
creatures to to all the other creatures
on earth
man is characterized by a number of
things so one of them is
he's the only animal that knows he's
going to die someday
and knowing that
he also has an obligation to make the
most of whatever time he has
and making the most of it is enormously
assisted by reading by learning about
the world
learning about the past and the present
and an ability to look to the future by
by reading i want to tell our audience
if you've just joined us shelby foot
will be with us for another 2 hours and
45 minutes and in about 15 minutes we'll
go to the phones give you a chance for
two and a half hours to ask him any
questions you might like to
ask him about anything including all the
writing that he's done uh
what else are your favorite things in
this room
on
that's a that's a very large question
because i tend to put my favorite things
back here we're going to talk about all
that over there when we get into the
your seat over there we got the music
over here that music over there and uh
modern literature mostly over here
although it starts as old dickens all of
conrad
jane austen
uh one of the best faulkner collections
in the country there you read it all
oh yeah
and over again
what i appreciate more about reading is
rereading
i'm a writer it's my craft
and when you re-read a book
especially by a real good writer
you enjoy seeing how he goes about
getting where he's going because you
know where he's going when you reread
and you see him prepare for for what's
coming
and uh the skill with which he does that
is enormously instructive to a writer
when you read what's the circumstances
it's uh it's a funny thing i've talked
to people about their reading uh
i do not see
a scene when i read i read words and
even punctuation
a lot of people they tell me when they
read it's like looking at a movie they
see the characters and what the author
is saying they're doing of course i do
that to some extent but mostly i'm
looking at the way he
moves words around
i remember reading somewhere about you
that
back at the university of north carolina
at chapel hill you got lost in the nine
stories of stacks in the library i
didn't get lost i was very much happy to
be there i i
i imitated a graduate student and i
would get in the cubicle and and all
this nine stories of books i've never
seen anything like that before
and uh to me
the university is a library it's a group
of buildings around it
and uh i spent more time in the library
than i did anywhere even the fraternity
house classroom
no matter it was the library that i was
just fascinated with fun
it not only was
was there all of shakespeare there there
was all the books about shakespeare
there what kind of music
do you add to your life from over here
uh two kinds i'm crazy about classical
music in every sense
and i'm also a big fan of the blues
uh robert johnson especially but bessie
smith
and a great many others
we talked one time many years ago that
when you listen to music you don't read
no uh
i can listen to music while i'm going to
sleep
but it's a distraction i
can't can't put up with what i'm trying
to read i can't do both those things at
once
and so you look when you listen to music
you don't read when you read you don't
listen to music that's right before we
sit down a couple other things i don't
know this is going to work but let's go
quickly through the process here follow
me down
novel written what year that was written
it came out in 1950 this came out in 49
1950
51 52
54
and that one 70s
i think now these novels are about what
about the mississippi delta possibly
exceptional shiloh and there's uh one of
the characters in there is from my home
place
we go up the next level here and we have
the three volume set of the civil war
right
all non-fiction right i remember reading
that you said you read 350 books to get
ready to write that
uh i had about 300 books that i actually
worked with right over my desk i didn't
much go to libraries and i did not go to
original material
in the department of archives and
history i wrote from the printed word
but uh the civil war is so widely
written about
that you don't need to go back to the
original documents everything they've
all been gone over
over here is the shelby foot and walker
percy
that's correspondence that's our letters
we never knew those would be in print
and that's one of the nicest things
about them we were talking to each other
what about that friendship and
you know how valuable was it to your
life well we we were friends for almost
exactly 60 years
and i don't know how many people have a
friendship with the last 60 years but
i've never heard of two writers getting
along
for 60 years
so
how'd it start
it started when walker and his two
brothers moved to greenville
will percy their cousin and adopted
father
came to me at the out to country club
swimming
he came over and said these young people
were coming to visit him and he'd like
for me to help show him around town and
everything i said i'd be glad to
and that's the way we met what was the
best thing about walker percy
the best thing about walker pleasure was
walker person
you had to know walker to know what i
mean by that but anybody can appreciate
him by his work he's one of the great
writers of the 20th century
won't we walk over near your desk um you
you have your your friend proust is over
there above the bed
did you sleep in this bed while you were
doing your work uh quite often
how many days in a row would you when
you worked on your last volume of the
civil war in this room how many days
would you
submit this week straight through except
time i go to new york or something take
off
but uh i i found that skipping a day's
work would um [ __ ] me up for coming
back to work so i didn't skip a day what
was the longest stretch that you had
during that time where you'd write
you mean how many weeks i'd go without
without a break yeah oh
i might do that for two or three months
without a break well yeah i'm a slow
rider so it took took i had to work long
hours to turn out a 500
a 500 word day is a good day for me and
you you would not write more than 5 600
words a day that that was a sort of
average on i might take off like a
skyrocket and write 1200 1200 words
someday other days it might be 50 words
it's hard to say and this is the chair
this is the where you say
somewhere i read also this light
it's an old light
the first story
i ever sold was to the saturday evening
post
and they paid me what was then an
enormous sum
of 750 for that story
and i um
i bought three things i bought
this lamp
a shotgun which is in the closet there
and a leather jacket which is also in
the closet i still use all three of them
on that desk there you also use that dip
pen we talked about before
show us that the pen that's that's
that's the kind that used to be in post
offices
and uh finding points is an absolute
nightmare
finding blotters is a hard thing to do
and i don't know when there's a pen
staff but i don't worry about that
and i was lucky i found a whole bunch of
points
at a
dusty old stationary shop that used to
be on 44th street just down from the
algonquin
and i bought myself a lifetime supply
what kind of paper would you write on
that is a big problem i write on
typewriter paper
and it doesn't take ink anymore the way
it used to so i have a big problem with
paper now what's this i have in my hand
that's the manuscript of shiloh
and uh at the end of each day
i do the
the final corrected draft
and put it on the stack and then type
type it up
for the printer
is this the original or is this the copy
that's a final day's copy each day i
would do what i had done that day i
would end the day by making that
that final copy now you've got up on the
shelf there
how many other of your original
tournaments follow me down
dry season
shallow
jordan county's not up here i didn't say
those were there september september my
sixth novel
any idea how valuable those are
no
what are you going to do with them
leave them to my son
what about your
your uh
your work i mean your papers and stuff
they're in the southern historical
collection at chapel hill
uh i'm glad they're there it's a good
place for them it's a good collection
and what are some of the things that you
have there on the back of your desk
hold on
they're favorites of mines
jacob keats
them is girl the pearlier ring
myself as an old confederate scout
a birthday party when i was about 11
years old in greenville with all my
friends
bedford forest robert e lee
u.s grant
pat claiborne
somewhere i read where pat claiborne was
one of your favorites absolutely who was
it he's from arkansas he's an irish
immigrant
who became a lawyer and helena
and i was interested in the military
because he'd done a hitch in the british
army as a corporal
and uh
he's a marvelous general and his men
loved him he was killed at franklin in
the last year of the war
jake could we get a
really good close-up there on that board
just so folks can see it uh
not from such a distance why check off
and you mentioned him even earlier the
chekhov is a
he was born four years into this century
but he's as modern today as when he was
writing
jacob had a tremendous influence on the
writing of the short story
[Music]
all short story writers are influenced
for the good
by chekhov
jacob had a
had a
he had a talent that's not you can't
explain it walker and i used to try to
figure out he does these things that he
brings them off
we could never we could never figure how
he did it it's so good at this stage in
your life who do you enjoy reading the
most
always shakespeare and proust still
those are the standby
there are others uh john keats
robert browning
in our time
faulkner fitzgerald
uh and john o'hara who's practically
disappeared now
let's go to the calls uh shelby foot
will be with us for the next two and a
half hours and we've got some folks
waiting wanting to
talk to him about his life and his work
on this in-depth program on book tv our
first call is from arlington virginia go
ahead arlington you're on with shelby
foot
hi i'm a forensic scientist and i've
also done archaeology and i view both of
those as historical sciences
in the sense that you're you're
reconstructing the past and it's just a
matter of time frame really in
archaeology it's
hundreds or thousands of years in
forensic science
it may be a couple of hours or days or
weeks
but i'm wondering as a historian
how you view
the methodology of history
of being a historian
the methodology is
depends on the historian
i think that historians have a great
deal to learn from the novelist
the kind of research that you do
supplies you with the facts
and then you breathe life into those
facts by telling it well i don't mean by
pumping it up or making any false uh
elevations of the material
it's just do what a good
hard-working novelist does right as
truthfully as possible
and uh the the groundwork is done by
archaeologists if you will
but uh it's what you do with those facts
no list of facts if it gives you the
truth
uh
quoting keith uh keats uh
in one of his letters he said a fact is
a fact is not a truth until you love it
and by that he means i know how to
handle it
having a true affection for it
i'm not sure that answers your question
if you've just joined us we're in shelby
foote's
workroom bedroom uh
here in his home in memphis tennessee on
our in-depth program as we take another
call from las vegas nevada go ahead
please you're on the air
uh mr foot i have a question about
nathan bedford forest what made him such
a
tremendous leader of men
he was never educated as far as i
understand militarily what made him
so successful against the the northern
forces
forrest had a true
uh
native born genius
his education consisted of about six
months
uh he said a thing that make all writers
happy he said i never see a pen but i
think of a snake
forest
all his gifts were natural
uh he
is to me the outstanding genius of the
civil war i do not mean by that that he
could have been a better general than
r.e lee or
u.s grant
or some lesser people too
but
forrest could look at a piece of ground
and know how to use it
he could read as an opponent's mind by
transferring himself into that man's
position
and he's just a
miracle to read about
forrest has gotten a a bad reputation
with many people nowadays because of his
activities as probably head of the ku
klux klan immediately after the war
uh people ought to know too
that he dissolved that plan in 1877
uh that because it had turned violent he
was opposed to
clan activities that involve violence uh
they have to study a lot more about
forest forest was light years ahead of
most of the people in memphis with
regard to civil rights for blacks
[Music]
forests would take a lot of
understanding
because he's been so misunderstood let's
go to leesburg virginia for shelby foot
good morning hello there good morning uh
mr foote this is a honor to speak with
you i have two uh questions uh one is
have you the first one is have you ever
met a civil war veteran or people from
the era what was that like would you
learn from them and then the second
question is just broad what
led your heart to a love and a respect
for the civil war
in the first place yes i saw when i was
a boy
jefferson davis's home down on the gulf
coast it was called beauvoir
uh was the home of confederate veterans
and i went down as a boy about 10 years
old
and i saw perhaps 12 of them there
old men with beards
but they had a lively sort of cackling
humor to them it was a great pleasure to
be around
i heard a story about
about one of them
they have visiting days and the ladies
of the region would come
to see the old man and entertain them
and
a couple of women that were there and
there was a veteran who had lost a leg
in the war
and he was sitting in a chair over by
the wall
and the two women came and stood in
front of him and one shook her head and
said oh my
poor man you've lost your leg
and he looked down and said
my god if i haven't
they they were like that what i saw of
them they had mostly probably been drama
boys by then you know how many speaking
of beers how many have you had in your
life i'm sorry beards how many have you
had oh about four i started growing a
beard
when i started writing civil war to find
out what it was like to to have a beer
so i've had it ever since i shaved it
off every now and then i've had this one
for 20 years without you long beans
california go ahead please you're on the
air
uh yes uh mr foote it's it's absolutely
a wonderful pleasure to to have the
opportunity to speak to you
you were the one that got me really
started on the civil war uh i had uh
my
grandmother's first husband died in
libby's prison
and uh
i
saw ken burns's series on the civil war
and i retired in 1991 i'm 69 years old
and i started reading then and i haven't
stopped reading about the civil war yet
your series of books i have the three uh
volumes
and one interesting thing that i found
about
uh yearbooks was that uh the the south
was uh winning every battle that they
got involved in up until the the final
stroke i guess you'd call it then all of
a sudden
the union uh came out on top and it was
an interesting uh
uh interesting reading from that
standpoint i've read everybody i've
cleaned out all the libraries in long
beach and bellflower and all the rest of
them
but i understand why that happened and
i'm reading mr
lee kinnet's sherman at the present time
and the more i read the more detail i
get and the more understanding i i have
of the way you wrote those three volumes
and i want to thank you for that i
really appreciate it
i thank you as good you say that what
happened in the war
that made the south appear to be
uh much better
general
than in the north was that so many
southerners had been to west point it
was
quite common in the prominent southern
families for the youngest son to go
to a military life
and uh when the war came along they went
south with their states
and uh they were
probably the most capable
sherman whom you've been reading about
gave the explanation he said that it
took the northern forces
a couple of years really to learn how to
do what they were doing
and once they really got got into it
that's when the north started winning
and for the last two years
or certainly the last year
they were practically all northern
victories and that was because they had
learned in the hard school of combat how
to do what they had to do
talk about west point there's an email
we received in advance of the program
from a john viteretti
veterity
why don't civil war historians place
greater emphasis on the personal
relationships among the generals of the
opposing armies other than armistead and
hancock
for instance the
longstreet was best man at grant's
wedding
or those other confederate generals who
were president with lee at appomattox
all of whom grant had prior personal
relations with
that is stressed by most historians i
think he'll find that most of them do
one good example is schofield
and john bell hood had been roommates at
west point here they are opposing each
other
and schofield said later that he saved
hood from being flunking out of west
point by coaching him on mathematics and
he said sometimes he thought that was a
mistake
oxford maryland you're on with shelby
foot go ahead please uh yes sir um my
question is concerning the battle of
fredericksburg and i often wonder why in
doing a little bit of research i've done
on the civil war and in looking at what
fiction writers have tackled that why
this battle that was so important for
the south often seems ignored among
fiction writers and historians and i was
wondering if you had any comments
did you say clarksburg no fredericksburg
fredericksburg
oh i i don't know of a civil war
historian who doesn't give prominent
attention to gettysburg what happened no
fredericksburg fredericksburg what
happened to fredericksburg at
fredericksburg was a terrible union
defeat led by burnside who attacked an
almost impregnable position and was
simply slaughtered doing it but
fredericksburg is interesting for other
reasons than being a great confederate
victory
i don't know of any soldiers in the war
who were any braver than those men who
charged the stone wall at the foot of
mary's height
fredericksburg is a
is a hell of an example of northern
courage
being matched against a southern
so-called a-line
southerners should have great admiration
for for the northern army the way it
behaved in that the greatest perhaps of
its defeat did you go to the
fredericksburg battlefield and your
research i went to all battlefields and
i tried my best always to visit them and
the anniversary of the battle so that
the weather and the leafage on the trees
and everything would be as much like
that time as possible those things are
very important to get the feel of the
place we're in memphis were there many
battles fought around this area
the closest really sizable thing is
shallow
which is less than a hundred miles to
the east of here
and uh that's one of the great battles
of the war the first big one
and uh there's bryce's crossroads down
the way
it was a very brief and disastrous naval
battle here in memphis in which all the
confederate boats were sunk except one
that managed to get away
memphis right along the mississippi
river we go to fresno california for
shelby foot hello there good morning uh
first of all i would like to say to mr
lam thank you very much for unc span for
presenting book tv on the weekends i am
a great fan and i also have all your
books and i'm a great fan of those too
for mr foot it's a great honor to speak
with you this is about writing i have
always been a great reader of both novel
and non-fiction and and maybe you can
demystify for some of this for yourself
and and contemporaries
what takes you from loving books to be
actually able to write books i've always
wondered what that golden key was and
envied it and i also greatly admire
library and envy that too thank you
there's been several people who
expressed a a
sort of answer to that
robert louis stevenson i think he'd once
said uh
one way to learn how to write is to play
the sedulous ape as he said
pick a writer that you really like all
the way from dickens on down
and imitate him
until you can do a pretty good job of it
then
establish yourself based on that that's
stevenson advice
and he's quite right about learning from
other writers that's the way he learned
to write he learned it right through
reading intensively
trying to understand how the man did
what he did
and that's where re-reading comes in
especially handy when you know where
he's going you can appreciate how he
goes about getting there and you also
learn that language has rhythms
you learn that there are balances that
can be achieved and the last thing you
learn is how to plot a book
did you ever copy anybody yourself
absolutely uh i copied browning
faulkner all of them uh so do all
writers i don't know of any writer who
didn't begin writing because of the
tremendous influence of someone or or
many writers how often were you in
faulkner's presence and what was your
relationship perhaps uh 10 10 or 12
times spent the night in his house took
him up shallow once to walk over the
battlefield
he was an outgoing friendly
really nice man
most people say he was a
bumpus and so forth
he was only that way from somebody who
wanted something from him i never wanted
anything from an accepted company how
what was the difference in your ages
the fault is about 15 years older than
me when did he die
he died this is almost unbelievable he
died in 62
and it's hard to believe he's been dead
that long
nashville tennessee you're on the air
with shelby foote
yes mr foote
i wrote a lot in college and uh then i
got a phd in physics and taught college
and taught high school and i've dug out
a lot of my college stuff since i'm
during retirement and
have several ideas about
writing and uh how do you decide which
one to devote your passion and time to
and sort of a second question why hasn't
someone written a great epic
novel about the terrible battle of
franklin tennessee
the first one is uh i don't think you
need any encouragement or anything else
it's if you want to be a writer you'll
be a writer the way to learn to write is
by writing over and over again
practice describing something that you
see
practice uh
describing someone crossing a room
practice writing about someone laughing
or crying
until you get it to satisfy you then
you're ready to really
start as for a novel about the battle of
franklin
uh franklin is
one of the most horrendous things in
american history
you saw an army practically destroyed at
one stroke who'd ordered that that that
attack and the army of tennessee came
close to going out of existence which
side
the confederate side nearly went out of
existence there uh
they fought the battle of nashville
later and then wound up fighting some in
north carolina
when the war was approaching its end but
it was never really an army after it was
wrecked at franklin
uh who had ordered that that thing out
of anger
he was trying to discipline his army
tried to get him to do what he called
right over and over again they kept
disappointing him and it's as if he said
by god they will do that they could
charge these press works and then then
maybe they'll do right
it was disastrous he really ruined his
army pat clavin was killed at franklin
prescott valley arizona you're next with
shelby foote
good morning
hi hi um mr foot what an honor
um a little while ago you spoke i have
two things kind of to mention here a
little while ago you spoke about
um
people who when they write novels if
they're good can we just say what can we
just say about miss mitchell when she
wrote gone with the wind a lot of us i
was just a kid when i wrote i'm 70 now
and i
when i read it i was just a kid but i
kept reading it every once in a while
and i learned the southern side
of the war between the states
and i felt that that started my
curiosity about that war also having
been born on the 4th of july
i recall walking through gettysburg
and the hair literally standing up on
the back of my neck as such an honor to
be in such a hallowed spot and thank you
for writing all those books is that one
of the reasons you wrote them that's
because you felt so close to them having
been born there in the middle of all of
it
yes
i would be in new york and uh there'd be
a bunch of us either in a nightclub or a
restaurant or a hotel lobby or sitting
around a room talking
and somebody would say to me are you
from mississippi aren't you i said yep
uh why are you people so crazy about the
civil war and it wasn't i who brought
civil war up it was it was he who
brought it up
and uh
it's only natural
that we should be we southerners should
be interested in civil war if there was
fought now own
backyard
the other reason we remember it is
when i was a boy and a young man
all arguments between boys were settled
by some kind of fist fight
mostly pushing matches and so forth but
fights
and those you remember with the greatest
clarity are the ones you lost
and that's one reason that the south is
so hyped on a civil war they lost it
and i had to accept the consequences of
having lost it
as for going to win
uh
i think you'd do better to go back and
read vanity fair which is taken from
there's a new book out called the wind
on gone
and it's much criticized for
uh what it did with uh
miss mitchell's book
but she did pretty much the same thing
although in a different way
to to
to to fantasy fair
uh
rhett butler and ron
crawley are
very similar friends scarlett o'hara and
what's her name
uh becky sharp are very much similar
there's nothing unusual about that
many great books get rewritten over and
over and over again thank god
dennis massachusetts you're next go
ahead please yes mr foot it's an honor
to speak with you i have a comment and a
question a comment is about your problem
with paper
as a calligrapher i use the inkjet paper
and it has a better tooth to it so that
you don't have a problem with the paper
and there's a bookseller in greensboro
john neal booksellers that carries a lot
of nibs and things if you ever run out
my question is i notice that you seem to
have a fob coming out of your pocket i
wonder if there's any significance to
the watch that's attached to it
and as someone who had family who fought
on both sides of the civil war do you
think the south will ever get over it
thank you i'll hang up and listen
they may get over it in a sense of not
continuing to talk about it continuously
but it's in our blood and bone
we won't get rid of it and our children
won't get rid of it and they shouldn't
get rid of it they should learn from it
santiago's think about people who don't
uh know their past or be obliged to
repeat it
is a very real danger
i think it's important that people
know the history of their country and if
possible the history of the people who
existed before this was a country
[Music]
you can't know too much about
where you live
if you want to understand the nature of
man
you are a person
and you live in a place and the more you
know about that place
the more you'll learn about that person
whom you are
and it's uh who you are it's a
it's a it's it's a
the thing that
harold bloom was talking sooner earlier
in his book about how important writing
and reading are
and uh
that can't be stressed too strongly
it's the reading of books
the absorbing of all they have to teach
us and especially the way they go about
teaching us
that set us off from other creatures on
this earth uh anybody who neglects
reading is making a
a terrible mistake and missing a
glorious time the watch farm
oh the watch
this is watch my wife gave me
my father's watch was very much like it
and it always hung right here on a peg
on my desk and uh one day i was in the
kitchen the only time in my life i ever
baked a cake
i was baking this cake and i came back
my watch was gone somebody would come in
the door here and lift it off there and
that broke my heart because of my
father's watch
and my wife got me this one to take once
you hold it up so we can get a close-up
shot of it while we take the next call
what uh year did she uh get this for you
i think this must have been about 62 or
three or four or five
let's go to honolulu next go ahead
please you're on the air
yeah this is uh i'm falling from
honolulu and just like the first of all
i just finished reading your trilogy of
all three 3 000 pages
and i'm 59 years old
and also you read it all i read it all
and how long did it take you oh that's a
year
it's taken me over a year
let me ask you the same questions
same question i asked shelby earlier
when you read it what atmosphere did you
create for yourself
um it was more of a cultural
experience my family historically i did
not know
came from the south
and so it was lost and then uh i just re
oh
when the
series came out with ken burns and
shelby foote was talking about it i went
back and started researching my family
came from the south
it was like there was a hole there for
the whole family
and so it sort of renewed that we had
southern ties
and but go back to the reading of the
book itself how did you read how many
did you how much did you read at any one
time
oh about 300 pages it would take me
maybe sometimes because i had to work
so i would do it late afternoon and uh
sometimes maybe i don't know what
what impact did it have on you and what
did it change what perception about the
civil war changed in your own head well
i had no real experience of the war
itself
because
i just didn't know i was just really
ignorant on it even the generals
had a huge impact in regards to me in
regards to pete longstreet
and the relationships between the
generals i had no idea
that they even knew each other
so the historical there was a huge void
i knew nothing about the south because
i'm basically came from
california so i had no historical and
they completely my family completely cut
it off
my grandfather great grandfather fought
in the south
he fought
for the stove i don't know i think he
was under joe johnson uh
during the war at uh
army at tennessee
so that means
right and so that's helped me just re
sort of recreate my southern roots and
uh when i was a young kid i just
couldn't believe that
you know we sort of had this
affinity for the south and i don't know
where that came from and now i know
so i just want to really thank
uh shelby foot in regards to helping
restore part of my culture
and thanks caller for for calling uh
those who've just joined us were in
shelby foote's bedroom where he wrote
the last of the three-part narrative on
the civil war a million and a half words
right what's your reaction when you hear
somebody like this say they
immersed in your work uh
what pleases me both is they said
they've
finally begun to understand the civil
war
and i'm particularly pleased to hear him
mention longstreet one of my great
favorites among the generals also a
misunderstood man
you meet these people
and
they're operating under terrific
pressure
uh and it's a it's a marvelous chance to
see man at his best and worst
uh and these people uh when you're
writing about civil war
there's a grievous danger
of overriding the thing is already so
lurid that you have to bring it down to
make it believable
it's a wonderful subject to write about
hagerstown maryland you're next with
shelby foote go ahead
hagerstown maryland you're on the air
let's go to las vegas nevada las vegas
you're on the air go ahead please you're
on with shelby foot hello
yes my name is dino smallis and uh
i have been a long admirer of you shelby
you've really influenced me not only in
this series about the civil war but in
the way you write your comments your
input
the insights you have on
individuals because of you that whole
series was just so amazing to me and i
think you've made it
i also i'm thankful to be talking to a
living legend you've inspired me a lot
being a fellow artist it's really
important to talk to somebody who's
still alive
and i've met a lot of artists and
everything in my time and it's always an
honor my questions are two part one is
um
if you collect any memorabilia of
anybody in the civil war that's your
favorite whether it's a soldier or
whoever you know personal items or
writings or
mementos and two
during your observations on all this
have you ever found out who the soldiers
are that live the longest and also died
the quickest in battle
i don't have any questions to that last
one uh
you're you're right about
the ken burns thing and and it can ought
to be given credit
uh he had a great mass of stuff to fool
with and he's the one who organized it
and picked out what order it would
appear in and how much of each thing
uh
he did a marvelous job on that
and uh people are always praising
uh
us participants
but it was ken who got that whole thing
up and was responsible for getting it
out the way he did
collectivist
i never was one to collect memorabilia
or weapons or things like that i have
some things a prize i've got my great
grandfather's uh
confederate veteran
papers
he commanded the knock jubilee cavalry
at the battle of shiloh
and uh i i i treasure the memory of him
and uh his his career during the war
but
the war has so many things about it that
you find attractive and uh
and uh
it's just hard to separate any one thing
from another but as for memorabilia and
equipment i never cared much for that we
have a little over two hours to go with
shelby foot from his memphis home we're
gonna take a break in a few minutes but
first halvertown
pennsylvania go ahead please yes sir
good morning thank you for taking my
call uh mr foote this is truly a treat
for me to speak to you sir i i have
admired you for years my question to you
sir is concerning lieutenant general
stonewall jackson had he survived
chancellor's bill sir do you believe
that the outcome of gettysburg and
eventually the war could have been
somewhat different
thank you
thank you
uh i've never been one for dealing much
with uh might have beens and what ifs
but in gettysburg if jackson hadn't died
at chancellorsville and had been command
of a corps
that uh yule commanded uh he certainly
would have taken cemetery hill
uh in jackson's nature not to stop until
he got it gotten every ounce of benefit
he could get
but that doesn't mean the battle of
gettysburg
would have been a confederate victory
the battle of gettysburg would have been
a brief
three or four hour
the real battle would have been fought
down on
about 12 miles away where mead was
preparing to fight it and it would have
been a different story entirely
if you start speculating as to what
would happen
you've got a whole jumble of things on
your hands that you can't handle
but unquestionably if jackson had been
there he would indeed have taken
cemetery hill which you will fail to do
but in that case the union army simply
would have retreated to the line made
was drawn 12 miles away
and it would have probably been a very
similar battle to the one at gettysburg
although
mead had a position in gettysburg it was
the closest thing to a molded castle out
of the middle ages the world ever so on
marvelous defensive position atlanta
georgia go ahead please
mr foote um
you mentioned walker percy and i
understand you grew up with the walker
percy
um the the percy family it seems that
currently uh william alexander percy who
wrote lanterns on the levee and that is
still in print has come under some
criticism and i wondered what your
assessment of william alexander percy is
caller what was the criticism that
you've seen
um that the percy family was
sort of lured over
the um the whole entire greenville area
for a number of years
and some of their decisions concerning
the help in the flood were
incorrect decisions are in error
that all comes out of a book published
about three years ago called rising tide
it's about the flood and the delta
and uh
[Music]
that has promoted a lot of criticism of
of will percy
uh
first place
uh
i saw the halfway grew up in the percy
house and mr will was
a mentor if i ever had such a thing
he was an absolutely marvelous man to be
around
will percy could talk to you about john
keats
and you paid him the supreme compliment
of wanting to get the hell out of there
go home and read some keats
he was that kind of teacher he was that
kind of man
uh the criticism of him
uh is is based on something that's
partly fact uh the percy family did
dominate in a lordly way that section of
the country
but you got to see what came out of it
uh
in greenville
uh
the ku klux klan never made any headway
at all
the citizen council was ineffective
there were no
rocks in greenville that's partly
because of the leadership of the percy
family not only mr will
but
the boys that were there after he was
gone
you have to be cautious about
criticizing people
because they exercise a certain kind of
power
their powers for good as well as bad
and the percy family
distinguishes greenville in other ways
greenville had more riders per square
yard than any town in the united states
that i ever heard of that was largely
because of will percy being there who
else was from there
hardy carter
walker and me
charles bell
there are about 12 riders from from
greenville it's very strange it's uh
it's like lightning struck a certain
place or something anna cortez
washington for shelby foot hello mr foot
what a treat
hey i've been an admirer of yours for
years and years and um i'm also admired
of long street
and i've been wanting to ask you for
years
what was going through lee's head at
gettysburg
when he did the same thing
that
would thickest charge
he did it fredericksburg that worked so
well for him he did against him and why
wouldn't he let hood and long street go
around to the right which seems like a
a smart choice to make just go around
and come in behind the union army and
not
charge
not make pick a charge at all what was
going through his head with that
i don't know what was going through his
head neither does anybody else and i
resent anybody trying to tell me what
was going through his head
uh
what happened was lee committed
probably the biggest mistake made by any
general on either side when he ordered
what's called pickett's charge on the
third day at gettysburg
but that's what's so interesting about
gettysburg the first day
if it hadn't been for hill
for euro holding back
uh he would have uh taken cemetery hill
and won the battle all in one day
and the second day he gets man right up
there on the ridge
fixing to go over he's looking into the
yankee rear
and he thought the third day this will
do it there's no doubt about it i came
so close on day one even close on day
two here on day three all we have to do
is press it and we've won
the result was the biggest mistake as i
said if any general mate on either side
at gettysburg there were 50 000
casualties and over half of them were
confederate mainly because of that
charge on the last day pickett's
division lost approximately 70 percent
of its strength in that one charge
and i don't know how i don't know how
those men bore that kind of losses i'm
talking about the men who ordered them
into battle
when lee went to bed that night finally
it must have been terrible for him to
think of all those dead virginians out
on the field as a result of his orders
if you joined us just a few months ago
we are with shelby foote in his memphis
home and we're in a room where he spent
a lot of time since
1967 or 66 66 66
how much has been written in this room
all of the third volume and another
novel
the sixth novel
and a number of
articles pieces what part of memphis is
your home in
it's almost the geographical center of
the original sort of memphis that was
here when i moved here in the 50s
and are you writing anything else now
nothing of any real importance i'm
writing forwards to books like
the studies of chekhov and various
people
we'll be back with shelby foote for
another two hours to take your calls
after a short break
book tv's in depth with shelby foote
will return in just a moment
next month on in-depth
historian richard brookheiser senior
editor at the national review and
columnist for the new york observer his
many books include the outside story how
democrats and republicans reelected
reagan
the way of the wasp how it made america
and how it can save it so to speak
founding father rediscovering george
washington alexander hamilton american
and his new book america's first dynasty
the adams's
1735-1918 coming out in february
join richard brookheiser as he discusses
his views on history current events and
takes your phone calls on in depth
october 7th beginning live at noon
eastern 9 a.m pacific time
labor day on c-span 2 is all about book
tv's in-depth interviews
at 8 a.m eastern we begin with studs
turkle
at 11 it's james macpherson
at 2pm it's in-depth joan didion
at 5 william f buckley talks about his
life and works
and prime time starts with gore vidal at
eight eastern
followed by stephen ambrose at 11
eastern eight pacific
then in depth tony morrison is our
overnight feature at 2 a.m eastern 11
p.m pacific
and in depth norman put hornets
completes the special series starting at
5 am eastern 2 pacific on tuesday
book tv's in-depth interviews all labor
day and night starting at 8 a.m eastern
on c-span 2.
book tv's in depth with shelby foot will
air again tonight in its entirety you
can see the writer playwright and civil
war historian discusses life's work and
the writing process tonight beginning at
midnight eastern
my hope is that this festival will
encourage a whole nation
to read together on september 8th
and i hope you'll join us here for in
our nation's capital for an
unforgettable experience cover to cover
thank you all
next saturday on c-span 2 book tv live
from the national book festival our
coverage begins at 9 30 a.m eastern 6 30
pacific and you'll hear from authors and
editors including stephen ambrose
nathaniel philbrick
david mccullough
john hope franklin
marie arana
liz carpenter and george will
the national book festival live next
saturday all day starting at 9 30 a.m
eastern and 6 30 a.m pacific only on
book tv only on c-span 2.
the vicksburg national military park was
a recent stop for the c-span school bus
there the crew learned about the siege
of vicksburg during the civil war the
civilians of vicksburg suffered the same
hardships as the confederate soldiers
defending the fortress city on the river
at the outbreak of the siege general
grant the union commander sent in a flag
of truce informing the civilian
population that they were being given an
opportunity to leave the city but this
would be the only opportunity they would
get otherwise they would be subjected to
the same hardships as a confederate
garrison
roughly one half the civilian population
left at that time the other half roughly
two thousand twenty five hundred people
remained in the city of vicksburg and
there they were pinned just as with the
garrison for the long 47 days of siege
during the course of the siege of
vicksburg rations for both citizens and
soldiers alike
grew scares
in order to conserve what food supplies
were on hand general pemberton the
confederate commander ordered the
rations immediately cut to three
quarters of standard issue
then the half
then the quarter
then they were cut again
and yet again
and yet again
by the end of june the garrison of
vicksburg was subsisting on a handful of
peas and rice issued once a day per man
it's not very much to maintain your
strength upon but it is all they had
even their water was rationed to just
one cup per day
the citizens on the other hand had their
own food supplies available to them they
were off limits to the army but even the
civilians found themselves rationing
their own food to ensure that it would
last throughout the siege of vicksburg
by many accounts you could go down to
the marketplaces on washington street
and there see skinned rats hanging for
sale they went for an exorbitant price
only the very wealthy citizens could
afford them
to avoid the shelling of the union navy
citizens fled to caves that were carved
into the hillside scattered about
vicksburg and there they lived like rats
underground for more than six weeks
about the only time they came out of
their caves when the union guns fell
silent as the cannoneers were eating
their morning noon or evening meal by
all accounts that as the citizens
emerged from these caves they were ash
and white in complexion very frail but
they withstood the hardships of the
siege without muttering a single word of
complaint
they offered words of encouragement and
support to the garrison of vicksburg and
hoped that it would help sustain them in
defense of the city
on july 4 1863 the siege of vicksburg
ended with the surrender of confederate
troops to general grant's union forces
this is book tv on c-span 2.
if you'd like a videotaped copy of the
programs you've been watching this
weekend or any weekend on book tv
call one eight seven seven on c-span for
pricing information or to request a tape
or go online to c-span dot org slash
shop and click on book tv
we're back in memphis at shelby foote's
home in the middle of the city
and the camera soon will show you the
little lounge outside of the bedroom
here where mr foot did his interview
with ken burns in 1990 for the civil war
series and
a lot of his books there on the back
shelf as
jake walks into the room here with a
camera on his shoulder and shows us
where we're going to be located for the
next two hours shelby foot i have a
email here from david lammon
valdosta georgia can you compare and
contrast the treatment of the
confederate prisoners by the union with
that of the union prisoners by the
confederacy
that's rather difficult to do
there's been a great many exaggerations
on both sides
and there's a terrific amount of
suffering on both sides so it's hard to
exaggerate what they've managed
andersonville
was supposed to have about a fourth as
many men in it as were in it
and they had to subsist on
about what the confederate soldier was
getting to live on
which wasn't really enough for anybody
to live on but the soldiers out where he
could scrounge around and find something
else these prisons in andersonville
couldn't
the northern prison camps camp chase and
various others
had the added
discomfort of people freezing to death
there was some serious
serious
deaths resulted from that
[Music]
the medical side
of the civil war is very interesting uh
a great many men died for instance with
measles
uh we don't think of measles as being a
killing disease
there's a new uh
medical
center for the civil war
at fredericksburg uh uh
frederick maryland
uh that uh is very good on that kind of
thing and you can go to andersonville
now it's become uh
it's become a park where you go to and
you can see what horrible things happen
there
[Music]
andersonville is in georgia yeah it's in
georgia uh
the trouble was
there was no organization
by the prisoners themselves there were a
few if any officers in that camp that
was mostly fully enlisted men
and they formed gangs and uh did
terrible things to each other in
addition to what was being done to them
by the confederate gods and they were
being guarded by old men and boys
uh it was a
tragic thing to have happen and the same
way in camps in the north your trilogy
on the civil war
published over 20 years in may and a
half books when was the last word
written for the last of the three books
uh
it was i think on may day
of of uh 1974.
what'd you do that day
uh
i had an experience very similar
if i can boast a little uh to what
gibbon had when he finished the decline
in fall he said that when he finished it
he felt elation
and then he felt a great sadness as if
he'd lost a good friend he wouldn't be
working on his decline and fall anymore
i had pretty much that kind of that kind
of reaction urbana illinois go ahead
please you're on with shelby foot yes mr
foot um
i've read
i've read your three volumes twice
and uh
since then of course i've read quite a
bit of other stuff
and
um
i it got me interested in
not only the civil war but in uh of
course napoleon and uh and hannibal and
that's what i and and
the mexican war
and i call uh the reason i called is
i have written uh written a little bit
for my civil war roundtable about uh
about can i
and
c-a-n-n-a-e as everybody pronounces it
differently
but the reason i got interested in that
and when i first
was when i first saw it was of course in
your book
i read a few hundred books on the civil
war by now but
the only place i've ever heard seen that
referred to was in your book where
you would say that a particular general
was trying was hoping to convert this
particular situation into his can i
and uh so that when people ask me how
did you get involved in han he get
interested in hannibal i tell him that
and they say well where did he uh
where did he refer to that and i don't
know i just hope that you can remember
getting is is cited often in history
because it's a history it's the battle
that's the most complete victory
that you can have in war and all
generals are trying to
score another canadian where was it
it was in italy and they were coming
down out of the alps
i don't know the exact geographical
location of it
what do you think
is the best thing about your writing i
mean what what is it that you do
uniquely that no one else does
a person is not
very good at commenting about his own
work
alan tate pointed out one time that when
a writer talks about his own work a
specific page of it or anything else he
not only sees what's on the page he sees
that what he intended to put on the page
he thinks he put it on there and
sometimes he didn't
uh so a writer is not a very good judge
of his own work
but
if i had to um
say
what gives me the most pleasure about
what i've done
is uh
i think good writing is always tied into
speech
it should be able to be read freely so
that it flows in a certain sense and has
certain rhythms i try for that
and i hope i achieve it from time to
time now for those who've just joined us
you're sitting at your desk where you
wrote the last
of the three books on the civil war and
that light above it that fluorescent
lights you had for how many years
i've had that since 1947 i think or 8
whichever it was
and you still have the dip pen that you
use when you write right that's right
yeah do you have do you have anything
yeah you have ink in there yeah yeah do
you have the paper you would write on
right could you show us i mean we'll
take some calls here but can you show us
what it looks like when you're actually
writing on and the paper you're using oh
well uh
let's just take a piece of paper while
you do that i'll take this next call
from portland oregon go ahead portland
you're on the air
hi
pleasure to speak to you mr foote i'm
really interested in your uh perspective
on the civil war as well as your
perspective on your uh writing my
question is this i
have been doing some research on my
family and have found that my relatives
from southern kentucky
fought on the side of the north now we
often hear that
the civil war is brother against brother
and
i've never really found a good source
that talks about what was in the hearts
and minds of the individual soldiers of
why they would choose to fight for the
union or the confederacy in those border
states do you have a comment on that
it frequently was a family thing
you had some
northern
men who were generals in the confederate
army because they'd married southern
women before the war
and they went with their wife when they
came along you had seven men fighting on
the northern side george thomas of
virginia one of the very best of the
northern generals was a virginian
um
you went where
your
sympathies went
and uh the main thing was not to stand
aside
almost everybody was involved in that
war
especially southerners
on nolan side you could avoid
conscription by paying 300 every time
your number came up
uh but
as for
people from kentucky
or maryland
even tennessee where there's a divided
choice among the people
you went the way
your heart led you is the only way i can
explain it
kentucky is unusual
it had a star in the confederate flag
but it never see seeded
uh and
kentucky joined the confederacy after
the war was over
it was it was the confederate veterans
who got there all the political offices
in the years following a following civil
war wheaton maryland you're on the air
go ahead please i really appreciate
c-span's book tv it's a great pleasure
ma'am a
lifelong historian
but with speaking to mr foote i've a
native washingtonian and my mother's
people came from howard county maryland
and fought on the side of the north
but to make a long story short i just
finished a
contract up in boston and i've always
had to dissuade people from thinking of
dc as a northern city
you know which many of them do and i was
wondering if you could wade in on my
side here i'd really appreciate it
well it's uh it's sitting right there
between virginia and maryland
two seven states and of course
washington's the southern city the joke
is it has uh
southern efficiency in northern charm
which is a strange car what year did you
spend in washington i was in washington
as a playwright in residence at the
arena stage
in 63 and four
parts of both both those years i enjoyed
it very much i like washington and what
schools have you been a writer in
residence or a lecture only one i i was
uh
i spent a semester at holland's college
to pay my daughter's tuition
did she go there yeah let's go to san
bernardino california go ahead please
yes uh mr foote
um
a couple years ago i visited the
gettysburg battlefield and my surprise
being from california was a monument a
credit to the california regiment
but even more surprising than that was a
a story about a historical character
that really i can't understand why he's
in historical obscurity his name was
senator edward dickinson
baker and um he was abraham lincoln's
best friend he was i found out he was
instrumental keeping the western states
from seceding from the union
uh he was killed at the battle balls
bluff which then formulated
as a result the conduct of the the
committee the conduct of the war which
many felt had a negative impact
on
the union soldiers
i just i don't understand why uh this
man has never i in the general history
of the civil war you never hear about
this man and yet i think he was uh i
think he was also the only active u.s
senator
to be killed in action as acting as an
active army officer and i don't
understand he's a very interesting
character had a very great influence on
the civil war
and we never hear about him do you
have you've uh do you have any comment
on that
yes um baker's largely been forgotten
because he was a damn fool
he mishandled those troops and balls
rough something awful
uh he was quoting walter scott and
taking up a very dangerous position on
the lip of a bluff
[Music]
he was lincoln's best friend and it's
the one time anybody saw lincoln cry was
when he got the news of baker's death
but uh baker was pretty close to a total
loss militarily
what cities in the united states have
you lived in signs greenville and
memphis
i was in new york for a short period of
time worked for associated press out a
local desk there
uh and i have not lived in any other
city except that month
three months in washington
we've talked about this before but you
were a court martial when you're in the
united states army how many years did
you spend in the army
uh i joined the mississippi national
guard in
october of 39 after hitler went into
poland
and we were mobilized in november of uh
of
of 39
out of 40. and we went to camp blanding
florida
and i went from there to ocs at
fort sill oklahoma
came out of lieutenant
went to camp shelby mississippi
into camp bowie texas
and then went overseas from there
and was assigned to the fifth division a
lot of west pointers they've been in
iceland for a year or so
and i got crossways over lieutenant
colonel
on the artillery chief staff
his name was tuffy horner
and uh he and i had a concert talk about
his uh cussing one of my men
and uh
he laid for me and got me
for falsifying a trip ticket
whenever you use a government vehicle
you signed a trip ticket
they had an order that you didn't use a
government vehicle
uh for recreation beyond a radius of 50
miles
and we were the only artillery battalion
we were 52 miles from belfast it was
quite common among us to write down 49
miles so it's not to break the rule
about 50 miles and i was charged with
falsifying a government document
court martial and sent home right back
to the united states were you
dishonorably discharged
they called it other than honorable
which amounts to the same thing you got
back in the marine corps well when i got
to new york i went to work for
associated press and uh
all these things were going on out in
the pacific and marines and i went down
and joined the marine corps
and i went through boot camp at paris
island they had a good time with me
my fellow marines would say uh
i understand you used to be a captain in
the army you might make a pretty good
marine private
and when you got out of the marine corps
were you honorably discharged from that
yeah uh they did such a nice thing just
about six months ago
there's a major staff major from little
rock over here the marine corps
at the instigations from people in
chicago
they brought me a dress sword for the
marines and it has captain shelby foot
on the blade of it so i'm honorary
reporter promoted to captain america is
that what we have up here yeah it's your
phone next call corpus christi texas go
ahead please
hi um
i was making a trip through all the
civil war battlefields a few years ago
and we were talking to a little old lady
who was a librarian at the
lookout mountain i think it was and we
asked her if we'd she'd ever read shelby
foot books and she said well of course
i've read shelby foote's books but
i just want to say that but
i was wondering do you have an affinity
for southern soldiers that you didn't
have for northern soldiers like say at
the battle of franklin did it kind of
break your heart to see patrick clayburn
and go down
it sure did uh
[Music]
some reviewers have noticed that uh
i've been praised and i appreciate it
enormously for being impartial in my
history about uh northern and southern
forces but some of them said you can't
escape seeing that his art beats a
little faster when there's a confederate
victory and i suppose that's true
but the highest compliment i get is from
people who say they can't tell from
reading my book which side i'm i'm on
off for
but i i certainly have some southern
bars
a good example of selling buyers is when
you see a list of
people killing an automobile crash or
airplane crash
you look for southerners down the list
that's that's a good sign ellen
flagstaff arizona hello there
thank you see c-span for having mr foot
on today
and mr foot i'd like to ask you
when i read about the civil war and
try to comprehend what goes on
i lose
a timeline
i really can't seem to
get in my mind which order which battle
came first or last or whatever
and you as a writer you seem to have had
the advantage of visiting the actual
sites and
that would help you
understand it i understand that i
understand uh put together the timeline
can you make a recommendation of
anything to help me
get through this timeline problem that i
have
yes
read
the actual reports that you'll find in
the official records of the war the
rebellion it's 128 volumes you can pick
it up almost anywhere
and you hear them speak as they spoke at
the time that's a great value
reminiscences are good to read
orderly examinations of military
movements by modern writers are good to
read too
but the most valuable stuff is the stuff
out of that time so that you can get in
tune with the way those men felt
uh it's not hard to do because they
didn't hesitate to express their
feelings we have a guardedness nowadays
about expressing our feelings they
didn't have that
uh
they were not afraid that somebody would
scorn them for having this that or the
other and yet somehow they were not
really sentimental they had a had a hard
core of honesty about them it's
interesting to encounter we've gotten so
cluttered up nowadays we don't know what
is and what is in
except they pronounce everything is
sentimental
which sometimes i think is true st paul
minnesota hello there
hello st paul minnesota go ahead please
hi thank you this is such an honor
shelby foote has been
an absolute hero
i am one of those
old-fashioned little southern girls
raised by yankees i'll have you know my
parents were both northerners i was the
only rebel in my family
two things i want to make comment
i believe
i read an article a little article in
the newspaper
i'm from florida and i went to a high
school
in florida nathan bedford forest high
school
i caught an article
that
you
and his granddaughter i believe
if you could just confirm this i thought
this was a funny little story y'all were
playing with his sword
also if you could and i don't i hope
this isn't too touchy of a subject
i'm kind of brokenhearted about the
issue of the confederate flag
thank you again for the opportunity
first who is nathan bedford forest
nathan bedford forest is a memphian
he's a native of middle tennessee born
in chapel hill tennessee
lived most of his uh young life in
northern mississippi down there
especially in hernando which is about 25
miles from here and you got a picture on
your on your board better yeah this is
forest right here
[Music]
did you play with the granddaughter uh
his granddaughter was an old lady when i
knew her and i was very fond of them
and she let me swing
the general sable around my head a
couple of times i got a great kick out
of that
he had a funny thing i've told before
after i'd studied the war hard and
learned enough i thought a good deal
about it i called on the telephone
and said i've
i've studied this war hard long and i've
decided it had
two authentic geniuses
one was abraham lincoln the other is
your grandfather bedford forest and
there was a silence at the other end of
the line and she said you know it our
family we never thought much of mr
lincoln
she didn't like my coupling
grandfather with abraham lincoln all
these years later i told this story on
ken burns civil war thing and uh what
about the flag did always tickle me on
the confederate flag the flag uh i
regret very much what has happened about
the flag
the flag
that people look at now
is the flag that was carried during the
demonstrations against civil rights
it was carried by ku klux klansmen
all that kind of thing and that's what
it represents to a great many people and
i don't wonder that they're feeling pain
and wanting to take it down i understand
perfectly well they do that but to my
mind they're misidentifying that flag
that flag represents many good things
and you have to translate yourself back
into the time
of c-session
to understand how
some states should want to
see seed
the constitution has not been amended in
61 years this was the first amendment
the the the the
the emancipation amendment was the first
amendment in 61 years of constitution
and absolutely a first amendment that
ever had anything to do with anybody's
private property
so they saw this this amendment coming
uh they said we don't want any part of
this union we want to get out of it and
people who say slavery had nothing to do
with the war just as wrong as people you
say slavery had everything to do with
the war that was a very complicated
civic thing
uh
robert tombs or
somebody once gave the best definition
of that war i've ever heard he said it
was a war of one form of society against
another form of society and because one
of those forms of society
included
chattel slavery and the other side
didn't accept to a
limited extent
it's always been identified as a war
over slavery uh believe me no soldier on
either side gave a damn about the slaves
uh they were fighting for other reasons
entirely in their minds southerners
thought they were fighting the second
american revolution northerners thought
they were fighting to hold the union
together and that held true throughout
the whole war
except for some people who were absolute
partisans on both sides five years in
south carolina and abolitionists in
massachusetts uh but most of the people
were fighting because they were fighting
for southerners once said i'm fighting
because you're down here
uh if you want to invade my home you got
me to fight others say you're trying to
tear the fabric of the union therefore
you should be put down and not allowed
to do what you claim you want to do
it's a very complex subject and i'm
sorry to see it
degenerate into such things as
identifying that flag
as a symbol of of racism it is not it
was never intended as such
confederacy respected law above all
things
if you just joined us we're in memphis
tennessee at shelby foote's home in his
bedroom where he spent a lot of time
writing and did do you read in this room
i'm sorry do you read in this room
absolutely i've got an ames chair that i
sit in and read followers on in yeah do
you read by yourself
always why
i don't know it's uh
reading is a serious business uh and i
don't read it unless it's something
really interesting i found newspaper in
the morning at breakfast
uh i i have no patience with reading
trash i don't do it anymore how long at
a time will you read
oh a six hour stretch of reading is not
a long time
henderson nevada you're on with shelby
foot go ahead please hello um
my question concerns uh president
jefferson davis uh during the civil war
um
i find that he was greatly criticized
after the war was over and i would
wanted to get mr foote's impression
of his presidency and what he thought
perhaps were
his two or three best decisions that
benefited the south and uh opposite of
that
the decisions that detrimented the south
and what he thought of his overall
presidency
it's very difficult to
add
anything to what's gone on all these
years i i developed a great affection
for davis and a great admiration for him
i can quote robert e lee
who said he
he never heard of anybody he thought
uh would have done better than jefferson
davis and he personally didn't know of
anybody who had done as well
he was a great admirer of davis which is
a huge recommendation of davis davis had
a stiff
rectitude about him that uh repulsed
some people and it's the exact opposite
of davis and his natural state he was a
family man loved his wife his children
uh
and did so all his life he was warm and
outgoing but everybody took him to be
this cold creature
the devil incarnate and so forth davis
was not like that
he he had a code of honor that he obeyed
to his own conscience
that alienated him from people
one instance of it is
he had a friend in there he was an
officer in the army
a brigadier general matter of fact and
his superiors
wanted him uh fired because he wasn't
wasn't a very good officer and they came
to davis and said so and davis uh signed
his dismissal and the man came to him
and said you my old friend how could you
do this to me
and davis wouldn't betray what he felt
was a confidence with these superiors
who came there complaining about him so
he didn't want to make personal enemies
between these people and all he said was
you've got your orders and all you can
do is a bail milford delaware hello
there you're on with shelby foote hello
mr foote
um coming from a state that was uh
has been deemed a border state uh and
living in the southern part of the state
of the three the southernmost the third
county of sussex
we flew the stars and bars at the time
of the war and we also had a regiment
that fought admirally at
gettysburg from the north
one of the things that i have studied
and i have seen and i have a difficult
time grasping is the way that tactics
were used uh with regard to the
napoleonic system of warfare
i have read many times where you stood
shoulder to shoulder as we went
forward
but didn't we learn anything from the
previous wars as far as the indians and
the revolutionary war etc
and
people who fought behind trees and rocks
and things of that nature it seemed that
obviously i had a difficult time
grasping the fact that men would would
go
forward to their deaths
as far as that system of warfare was
being used and of course with the
weaponry changing at the time with
technology and and whatnot uh with the
mini ball and the rifled slug uh it just
seems to me that uh with the excellence
as far as knowledge that
men had at that time as far as being
generals and
captains et cetera et cetera down
through the ranks that we would be able
to get away from that that point uh as
far as the
knowledge was concerned and try to fight
a war
that was
utilized against us in the past i'd uh
like to hear your comment on that please
sir
uh you you're quite right you're on to
the clue of why casualties were so heavy
in that war
they believe that to mash your fire you
had to mash your men
so he lined up shoulder and shoulder and
went forward
and agreed to the dependence on the
bayonet frightening the enemy into the
retreating there were very few bayonet
wounds in that wall
uh and this lining up shoulder shoulder
and advancing
was uh
the reason for the huge casualties that
they suffered
uh
the battle of shiloh there were 100 000
men on that field there were twenty four
thousand casualties
uh by a coincidence that's the same
percentage of casualties as they were at
waterloo
when they entered the battle of shiloh
and saw the results of it
they should have said wait a minute
we're fixing to kill all the young men
in this country if we don't stop
and there were
another 10 or 12 shilohs down the road
in other words 10 or 12 waterloo's
but they seem to get more determined to
fight than ever the worst of it how the
castles were the more determined they
were to fight
it had uh something to do with uh
with
units coming from places uh
the
16th mississippi would all be from one
county somewhere or the 12th illinois
would be from some county somewhere and
those men had a closeness to each other
that uh
it just tears your heart to think of
them go through four years of war
a squad or say 12 men
and maybe two of them coming out alive
at the end of it and they're such close
friends all the way through it
that you would think somewhere would
stop
but there's another answer too that i
think carries maybe more weight
if i were one of picket soldiers lined
up there
and had a chance to look across that
field which is nearly a mile wide
downhill and uphill
all those guns laid training on that
open ground all those men entrenched and
waiting for me behind rocks and things
uh
i would have said uh moss robert i don't
think we'll do this thing
in fact i ain't going
but then you have to stop and think it
would have taken more nerve to say mars
robert i ain't going and would go
and those men felt that way about it
they were close to each other soldiers
know that they're dependent on each
other
and they're many factors that go into
their surviving those huge casualties
that they're suffering las vegas you're
on with shelby foot
shelby in relation to what you just said
one general comes to mind uh uh burnside
i believe his name was from the
from the north uh who
in my opinion slaughtered his men up uh
in more than one occasion
um and my question to you if you feel
the same is how a man like that could
get into the position
and retain it
and whatever happened to him
thank you
he he became commander of the army
potomac soldier by elimination
uh hancock turned it down
uh there was burnside to fall back on
and burnside was a very likable man
uh he was something of a pistol slapper
and a flamboyant looking fella but a
decent likable man
and uh lincoln thought he'd give him a
chance he looked like a man who might
accomplish something he was dreadfully
wrong and he later knew he was wrong
burnside stayed in the army until after
the crater affair down in petersburg
when he was sent home
but he was a senator after that had a
distinguished post-war career i always
liked burnside there's something
very attractive about him
[Music]
it's very hard to say
[Music]
on the confederate side there's bragg
who is a
was a sort of uh despicable creature
in many ways uh but i found him very
attractive in his uh in in in the way he
he handled certain situations that came
his way he was just tested by everybody
that was under him all over him
except jefferson davis who
who looked after him
but it's hard to make judgments on these
men
i like to think they all did their best
and and if they fail they fail
pittsburgh pennsylvania for shelby foote
hello um it's a real honor to speak with
you but you started to address this
before but what i'd like to ask is what
do you think now a lot of people are
saying that this war was nothing but
economic warfare on the south
what's your uh impression of that thank
you goodbye
i think we reached that point that it
used to be when two men got an argument
somebody said let's step out in the
alley and settle this it was almost that
benign
we think of ourselves as superior people
with a superior form of government
if we as superiors we think we all
wouldn't have fought that war we would
have done the thing we have a genius for
doing which is avoiding
uh
[Music]
confrontations we we
could we can find some kind of way to
get along
uh that time it failed
it did not work
and we had this terrible thing that
resulted in a loss
of 1 million 95 000 men
simply because we failed to reconcile
our differences
and i hope it was a terrible lesson to
us not to let something like that happen
again what was the split on the one
million ninety five thousand
uh the split was about uh i've forgotten
the actual figures northern cashiers
were much larger because they had so
much so many more men they had about uh
two million men the south had maybe
eight hundred thousand is that figure
including both killed and wounded killed
and wounded and even captured in many
cases stockton california go ahead
please
yes
you're on the air okay
this is uh
back to the military topic
i was commissioned into the army reserve
in kentucky in 1960
and
i
the unit that i was in spent
our summer camps at fort gordon
down in augusta georgia
and other units at
fort gordon
were from arkansas
and i remember this
major from arkansas
who was a farmer but he called himself a
gentleman planter
and he wore off duty he wore
cord suits with wide brim
woven
farmers hats
and
he didn't have to be in the reserve i'm
i'm sure he didn't have any statutory
requirement he was fulfilling
but
he just loved the army and he stayed
active and i'd like to hear your comment
about
the military tradition in the south
in the 20th century
he doesn't sound like a very good
representative of it but there is a
military tradition all was
any time you'll see a list of soldiers
or sailors or anything you you'll notice
a a large percentage of southerners on
it
there are a lot of reasons for that
a lot of people went into the army
instead of going to school because they
couldn't afford it a lot of women in the
army is liking it as a way of life
but
they've always recruited an awful lot of
soldiers from the south as compared to
other parts of the country
as for this fellow god knows what made
him the way he was
who in your family fought in the civil
war my great grandfather his name was
hezekiah william foote what was he like
i wouldn't know he died long before i
was born but uh
he lived to be
87 or 8 years old he was born in
the war of 1912 and died about the time
the spanish-american war was a hell of a
span of history
and he was from chester district south
carolina
moved to mississippi in the black
prairie region in about the 1830s and my
grandfather was his youngest son he's
handed and managed plantations that he
had in the delta there
you say
there's your picture in your history you
had two grandfathers that were rich but
died broke yes both but there's nothing
unusual about that well i'm from the
mississippi delta every family i know of
has been on top and on bottom
the credit's easy you go to the bank
you're a farmer
planter you go to the bank you want to
borrow thirty thousand dollars the
banker says why not take fifty so you
take fifty and comes due you lose your
land it happens all the time toledo ohio
for shelby foot hello hi uh first of all
it's a real honor for mr foote to
talk to you and that
and
two questions uh i'll try and make these
succinct has there been any literature
research on
whatever happened your typical soldier i
have a difficulty believing that they
experience this carnage of these battles
and go back to their farms in ohio and
mississippi
uh alcoholism drug use what was there
post
stress syndrome which we use with
vietnam soldiers i mean it'd be an area
i i don't know if it's been explored but
i'm curious about
how they survive mentally this uh
and secondly your opinion on
preservation of the battlefields and
that i i visited stone river last spring
and they've done everything except put
tunnels under this look like with that
urban sprawl from nashville
thank you
[Music]
you're quite right to wonder about all
those things as for the preservation of
battlefields
i can't begin to tell you how important
i think that is
uh when you know what happened on that
ground and you go stand there
uh something comes out of the ground i
it's hard to explain
how it comes about but there's something
that comes out of that ground almost i
have stood in what was called the bloody
angle of spotsylvania at dawn
and uh
i'll swear i was in the middle of the
battle of sponsylvania uh it's it's a
very strange thing it's a mystical thing
i can't explain it but it's very
important that that ground be preserved
because of this thing that i think
almost anybody can feel
you need to know a little bit about what
went on there and the more you know the
more real it gets but uh
you you you can really feel that you've
been where something happened when you
when you go to those fields what about
his other he parties talking about
post-traumatic syndrome yeah well uh
i don't know a tour in vietnam was a was
a horrible thing to go through
but imagine four years of carnage in the
civil war and the
post
dramatic syndrome the thing after the
war must have been terrific
uh a statistic will tell you and i a
partner
how horrible it was
the first year after the war the state
of mississippi spent on a solid
one-fifth of its revenues on artificial
arms and legs
uh that's how bad the war was in
mississippi
and uh how those men reacted
so far as i can see it was not like
vietnam it was not like vietnam they
remembered the war with uh
something closely resembling affection
it's it's not easy to explain
and i'm sure many of them had horrible
nightmares with things that they saw
anybody who went through
anything like like
the mule shoe at sponsylvania i don't
see i ever slept again in his lifetime
but they they took it they took it
remarkably well santa ana california go
ahead please you're almost shelby yes
hello my name is ian gujardo uh it's
nice meeting you dr foote
there's a couple of questions here one
of which the hundley is a big thing
right now discovered
just recently and the monitor was
discovered some years back and parts of
the monitor are being brought up but one
of the things being discussed today is
how the people died
in the hundley and what necessary
you know procedures they're going to
take to just determine
how those people died in the hundley
thank you very much dr shelby appreciate
it
what's he talking about he's talking
about the hundley the world's first
wartime submarine
and they have brought it up recently and
uh or they found the men inside it and
everything else and they they think they
know what happened uh the the window
that the commander looked out
uh
perhaps got crashed when they hit his
tonic and uh
and they they all drowned
uh
those very brave men i
every branch of the service has a horror
belonging to any other thing i can't
imagine flying around in the air where
everybody can see you and shoot at you
and i can't begin to imagine being in a
submarine under the water
that's a nightmare but these men
they were the third crew that was lost
in the hunley
uh they were lost of course for 150
years but um the first two crews were
lost just by accidents one time it took
the thing turned over another time they
don't know what happened they think
maybe somebody left the hatch partly
open or something
but
what happened to them is
they had originally designed
to use the hundley
towig a bomb on a 100-foot wire
and they would dive under the ship
surface on the other side
pull this bomb along so that it would
hit the ship and explode on contact
well they found that didn't work well at
all
so they decided to put it on us on a
long boom going out from the bow
and they had it there and that was used
in the attack they hit the ship and it
exploded but it also sank a hyundai
and it thanked the houstonic and the
hundley chesterfield virginia good
afternoon
yes hi brian hi mr foot nice for you to
take my call i appreciate it
um i have a two-part question for mr
foote the first is
the old stories about your
help as you write or who edits for you
or proofreads there's a number of tales
out there and
i wanted to ask mr foote to comment
about
the
the desk that's sitting there and tell
us some more about these ink pens and
who helps you with your proofing or who
edits for you and what are these old
stories the second part of my question
deals with
what i've read about the preservation of
battlefields across
the north and south what big
preservation initiatives have you been a
part of
what's a success story you could share
with us and what's a not so good story i
know living in virginia there was a
controversy several years ago in
northern virginia over disney world
wanting to take battlefield land and put
in amusement park and the longer you
talk mr foot the more i'll enjoy it sir
because i could listen to you for days
on end so thank you
thank you uh
to get to to disney first uh
it looked like we were not going to be
able to stop them
uh but we could and
i thought we were rather skillful in
that
the first place disney had opened a
thing in europe
uh that wasn't very successful
so they were a little cautious about uh
losing this and that in the oven
then the idea came along that uh mickey
was going to be associated with
desecrating hallowed hallowed ground so
that's what really made them back off i
think
but uh we got together and fought very
hard on that
a lot of people went into that fight and
uh they they want it because all of us
work so very hard to save that section
of manassas
incidentally it belonged to a kinsmen of
mine
name foot was part of that land at one
time
back to this desk she called up with a
series of questions and we started
earlier
with the dip pen and what i wanted you
to demonstrate i don't know if we can
get a good close shot of uh mr foot
writing but
you you said that you write between five
and 600 words a day right with a dip pen
on paper how many words would you write
how many words can you write each time
and demonstrate just for a minute there
how that would work it's uh
the reason i like writing with the dip
pen is it makes me take my time
you can't really see that but when you
see your hand is just
put
i just wrote it makes me take my time
and you can see it does make me take my
time and when you would write
how many you know the five or six
hundred words would take you how long
well it's writing and rewriting and
moving this around and moving that
around and that's the reason i like to
write with the pen way if i want to
correct something i do this instead of
taking a typewriter and reversing the
drama having a word processor where i
push key i don't want anything
mechanical between me and the page
now where's that desk from and how long
has it been here uh it's been here ever
since we moved in in 1966.
uh it's this is about two inches thick
here
and i've got it uh
tapered at the edge so it won't look so
thick
i had it built in here same way with
those bookshelves across the room
and this beaver board thing i've always
had to put my notes on
well i was right in the civil war
as close as we can get to that board up
there so that we can see what's on it
how many how long of those what's on
there been there oh a lot of things go
down other things come up
uh most of the stuff that's up there has
been there
some stuff has been up there for
40 years some other something that's
been up there for 40 years
well the thing that's been up here
longest is brugel's fault of the rebel
angels you can't see it now the varnish
is darkened on it so much
the uh
the keats death mask has been there a
long time
uh but forrest has been there a long
time
what about some of the notes any of
those notes up there i see some quotes
having to do with the novel i always
intended to write called two gates to
the city that i'm probably chief right
up there on that as close as we can get
pleased to that there you go and you
that's a novel you were going to write
yeah this is uh the outline of the
family and the outline of the thing
but i'm i'm not going to do it
when did you do the outline
oh
i i i've done that outline and redone
that outline i first started it way back
before i started civil war
and i dropped it to do the civil war and
when the war was over i went back to it
and found i couldn't pick it up i had
changed too much
what are some of the quotes up there i
think you had a keats quote or you you
were quoted about keats there's a
melville quote
saying the conflict
the conflict of conviction spins against
the way it drives
uh there's a quote uh
from uh
george lucas saying talent is always
a rightist deviation
tate writing to
somebody said uh
we live in a bad age
in which we cannot give our best but no
age is good
that's alan taylor
then there's a quote in print here
for me saying faulkner had the right
idea about mail
he held the envelope up to a light to
see if it had a check in it and if he
didn't he threw it away
somewhere i read that
you at one time knew langston hughes
or you were with him at uh walker
percy's house one langston hughes was in
greenville
uh he spoke
at a colored church there
and will percy introduced him
it was funny
mr will introduce him is delighted to do
it he respected hughes as a poet
uh but
langston hughes was at that time going
through a communist period
and it gave mr will lahore's entrance
introducing me made a sort of
communistic speech to the to the
congregation i've always thought that
was funny what other writers in your
life have you gotten close to
called a willingham who's largely
forgotten now
he and i were good friends do you ever
know cormac mccarthy i know you no i've
talked to him on the phone a few times
but i've never been in the same room
with him i've been a
champion of cormac ever since his first
novel came out
i've been preaching the doctrine of
cormac mccarthy ever since that first
book the orchard keeper came out
and he's beginning
has begun to get the recognition that he
deserves
heard uh
hair bloom in there a while ago on a
program on book notes
saying that
blood meridian
is perhaps the best american novel since
uh moby dick
which is quite
quite quite a compliment why did you
like or why do you like cormac mccarthy
the writing there's no writing any book
mccarthy writes the hero is the angus
language or the american language
strictly speaking let's go back to the
phones westerville oklahoma you're on
the air go ahead please
uh yes uh mr foot i'd just like to tell
you that uh you look much younger than
your age i'm quite surprised you're 85
and i hope that you're around quite a
bit longer
uh
i was curious if you have any any
interest in the other other wars other
than the civil war although i got to say
that civil war is my probably my
favorite
uh possibly even world war ii would you
experience
thank you
i um
if i had any other interest in any other
war
i would squelch it immediately i keep my
20 years and i got my discharge i'm not
fighting anymore i ain't going to study
war no more
uh i got various offers to write about
the revolution
the mexican war various things but uh
the civil war was enough for me that's
enough war harrisonburg virginia for
shelbyfoot hello
hello my name is phoebe davis and it's
such an honor to speak with you today mr
shelby
my great great grandfather enlisted into
the civil war fourth regiment of
tennessee in may of 61.
in november 25th he was wounded and
captured at missionary ridge
my question is can you tell me about
missionary ridge and and uh where is
that and did it have any significance of
the war
thank you again
it had a huge significance uh missionary
ridge was part of the battle of
chattanooga
george thomas's army
advanced on missionary hill and
everybody's surprised
not only made it up on the
up up the ridge up missionary ridge but
chased the confederate army off of it
and a full retreat
and on down into georgia further
it was the beginning of the end for the
army of tennessee although they had the
whole atlanta campaign to fight from
then on but when they lost chattanooga
it's as if the the gateway got knocked
off its hinges it opened the south up to
invasion of the kind that that sherman
did on the in the atlanta campaign
so
your great grandfather took part
in a in in a terrible terrible thing
that the army of tennessee people didn't
ever like to look back on
they uh they were routed
over here on the bed are all your novels
and your work uh six novels which one of
those sold the best
uh i think maybe shiloh sold the best
follow me down and dry season sold
rather well can you buy them all now
uh yeah they're all in vintage uh at
random house except tournament is
published by a small press in birmingham
and how about the civil war series is it
still selling every year it does indeed
sell quite well anybody use it in
classes in college
i think so i think so but i don't know
personally
it's too much to read for one thing
oklahoma city you're on the air yeah uh
dr foote
it is indeed a pleasure sir
um
i have a photograph that was handed down
from my mom
that
was made in
1912 in springdale arkansas
and it
includes um
five gentlemen from the north and five
gentlemen from the south but the one in
the middle
is my great great grandfather
and i've researched at pea ridge and
prairie grove and i've not been able to
find anything about what his battle
record was
how can i go about doing that
uh if you're a mississippian i'd send
you to the department of archives and
history and i'm sure they have such a
thing in arkansas and missouri where you
could uh ask them about his war record
uh if he held enough rank you could find
him in the official records war of the
rebellion
it's always the last volume of that is
uh is an index you can look him up in
that
uh
if you found what unit he was in if you
somehow managed to find that out you
could find a history of that unit
uh
you you could find a great deal more
than you think it's the best documented
war in a certain sense because of that
128 volume records war rebellion
and because of the care of the
department of archives and history the
national archives and history of gun
they've done a wonderful job of
preserving things a man there knew that
my
my great grandfather had been and he
sent me a whole bunch of documents
uh pertaining to him
including his uh request for a pardon
uh
and uh
they have complete stuff you you'll be
surprised how much you can find out once
you really get on the trail
el paso texas for shelby foot you're
next on the air
mr hood my favorite uh
general was hood and i wondered what do
you think would happen on the
second day if he'd have been allowed to
go around the union left
and secondly was he treated unfairly
later in the war was is it accurate to
say he was incompetent above the
division
level
or was he just misplaced in the uh
other command in the west which i
wouldn't use the word incompetent but he
did fail as an army commander what was
it let me just ask you what was his full
name john bell hood and he replaced joe
johnson and commanded the army of
tennessee and he said the second day of
what battle was he talking about he's
talking about gettysburg uh
long street wanted to go around the
union left
and hit him in the rear or take up
position that direction to receive
attack instead of giving it and hood
wanted to also independently long street
he had done his own scouting and one
strike in the union reel where they then
were
lee said no he's there and i'm going to
hit him and he wouldn't listen to either
long street or hood
who had made his attack
long street call
that day is fighting the best single
days fighting ever done by an army on
the face of this earth and they were
good too good man especially hood was
wounded there that's why he lost the use
of one of his arms san diego go ahead
please you're on with shelby foot
hello
please go ahead hi hi i'm calling
regarding uh andrew johnson um i've
heard you mentioned grenville tennessee
and i know he was from that area and i
was interested in your perspective as a
historian as well as a southerner
regarding andrew johnson remaining
on the union side when all the other
southern politicians had resigned and
went home
and my quick second question is for my
son i wanted to know is could you
explain the blue background and the
stars and the southern flag in the red
and why the colors are the way they are
thank you sir
uh well
johnson was from greenville tennessee
i'm from greenville mississippi
and his greenville has an e in it uh
g-r-w-e and e-v-u double-led uh
johnson there's some fixed
different opinions about
he appears to have been extremely
unskillful as a politician
he didn't couldn't get along with
congress and i'm not sure that anybody
could get along with that congress
but he he simply finished out his term
and there wasn't any question of his
being nominated for return because he
he he i always felt sorry for him he's
in an almost impossible situation
and he was a highly improbable sort of
person himself
he was drunk at the inauguration totally
by accident he was not a drinking man at
all he took a couple of big drinks of
brandy to keep his strength up
and and wound up drunk making a drunken
exhibition of himself at the
inauguration colors of the flag i don't
know how to explain any of that except
they wanted to hold on to the red white
and blue
[Music]
the confederate flag is basically the
saint andrews cross
and it had 13 stars on it even though
they wanted really 11 sea seeded states
missouri and kentucky had stars there
without having been officially seceded
or you can get some argument about that
particularly in case of missouri
the the flag tang
there were about six confederate flags i
don't know how many they are the one
we're most familiar with is the battle
flag
and it has come to represent the
confederacy and it's not unfair that it
should represent the confederacy i just
regret as i said earlier that it's taken
to represent things that it did not
represent it's not recognized for
representing the things that it did
represent
it wouldn't be vilified the way it was
if people would look at it the way it
was looked at when it was actually
flying and representing something except
a bunch of scamps out demonstrating to
keep people from having the liberties
they deserve
if you've just joined us we're in
memphis tennessee
in the middle of the city with shelby
foot in his bedroom where he's written
quite a few words read and also you
listen to music in this room too
yeah the music is a great and great and
great
great thing in my life it it means a
great deal to me particularly the
beethoven mozart the rest of them have
you studied those composers as much as
you've said this before no nothing like
as much but i did find out something
learning to read a score
is a tremendous help somebody
particularly if they have a
not superb hearing
when i look at a score of a quartet for
instance my eye will tell me my god look
what the viola is doing and then my ear
will hear it
but music meant a great deal to me all
my life i noticed on the board there on
in front of your desk there's a list of
composers
right that was to get straight in my
mind uh
the order that they were in
order of birth or
ordered that they did their uh
works
it's it's the span of their lifetime
the years they lived it starts with
sibelius
russell ravel and middle
and it goes down to tippett shostakovich
and britain
and i just want to get straight in my
mind the order that they
occurred north charleston south carolina
you're on the air
uh yes uh dr foote
i would like to ask you some questions
about the history of the state of west
virginia
they didn't become
actually a state of the union until 1863
and
most of southwestern virginia which it
was called during the first part of the
war
you had units in the confederacy
including the 45th battalion of virginia
infantry
which my great-grandfather fought in
and i also found colonel george s patton
basically the grandfather of the
world war ii general also fought for the
confederacy in the virginia 22nd
infantry
have you ever did any research on this
area sir
yes some
lincoln defended it
uh west virginia in effect seceded from
the confederacy
and they said to liquor and i thought
you were opposed to see session
and he said well c-session for the
constitution is different from sensation
against the constitution
you mentioned patton's grant's
grandfather
in the movie patton he stands in front
of this huge american flag and says we
americans have never lost war well
believe me his grandfather lost the war
pretty thoroughly he was in the army of
northern virginia
one of the distinguishing things he
saved the greenbrier from being burned
down
[Music]
by union forces coming through there by
driving them back
[Music]
patton is an interesting man to study
about
he's a man absolutely entranced with
military things of all kinds
military history especially roman
history
we have about 45 minutes left with
shelby foot
on our in-depth series on book tv as we
take a call from vinyl haven maine go
ahead please yeah good afternoon
i've been studying the civil war for
quite
quite a while now and i feel that the
high water back of the confederacy was
at chapsburg rather than at gettysburg
it seems to me after shaftsburg it kind
of went downhill from there i was
wondering what your opinion was of that
where is he talking about he's talking
about the battle of sharpsburg
which the south lost really at least
they defeated that they retreated after
it was over
uh i don't think they're wrong in saying
gettysburg
was a high watermark
it was the furthest north that
penetrated with a major army
uh it was a critical time
of the war
and
it certainly was downhill after that
especially since it's combined with the
fall of vicksburg in the west which is
ignored too much
the day
the last day of the battle of gettysburg
was the day before vicksburg surrendered
the vicksburg surrendered on the 4th of
july and leave retreated on the 4th of
july and it's often mentioned as the
high point of confederate hopes
and i don't think that's a misstatement
really a fact
i don't like
pointing out high points and low points
and all that but i think in this case
it's not unfair to say that
gettysburg is the high point even though
they it fell off from that high point
it will
it was indeed a high point today's
program is being produced by richard
hall and directed by maurice haynes we
take a call from peoria heights illinois
you're on with shelby foote go ahead
please
uh yes
this is sharon atterbury and i want to
ask about there's a location in memphis
i was just down there last week doing
research on a book i'm writing about a
lady who was a civil war nurse from
peoria illinois her name is lizzie aiken
she was known as aunt lizzie to the
nurses i went up on main street at the
corner of main street in jefferson
there's a very old building up there and
it says lowenstein's on the top of it
and i read in a book at the pink palace
museum that mr lowenstein came to
memphis in 1855 and opened his store in
1861. now is this or excuse me was this
part of the irving block prison or was
that in front of in front of where
irving black was thank you very much
it's a pleasure to speak to you
thank you
i don't know well enough the geography
down there as to the age of different
buildings and i don't think any part of
that prison is left
lawrence teams of course was department
store was very active here
for a long time
the yellow fever thing in memphis is
almost as interesting as the civil war
they were devastated here
memphis went out of existence became the
taxing district of shelby county there
were so many deaths
from yellow fever here and the
cemeteries are overflowing with people
from 1878 and 1893
yellow fever was a very real thing
in this this part of the country
san diego california for shelby foot
hello dr foote thank you very much for
taking my call this morning i've always
been a great admirer of yours i'm a
retired naval officer and a graduate of
the national war college where we
studied the civil war rather extensively
and i've always been uh intrigued by the
discussion of lack of follow-up at
gettysburg and other places
meets lack of follow-up at gettysburg
mcclellan's uh lack of follow-up at
antietam
in mcclellan's case despite his lack of
audacity and in mead's case despite the
momentum in his favor
i've always felt that the apparent lack
of motivation to follow up tactical
advantages in the civil war could have
been due in some part if not large part
to simply the feeling of enough is
enough
where the respect uh for one another as
countrymen simply overcame the bloodlust
and that
the idea of annihilation gave way to a
level of compassion that simply demanded
the victor allow the vanquish to leave
the field without further loss of life
could you could you comment on that
please
i think that you are
too hopeful of the goodness of man and
your uh assigning the reasons for no
follow-up to my mind the real reason for
no follow-up
from first manassas or bull run
right on through
up until the very end
the winner of a battle whether it was
gettysburg or fredericksburg
or manassas first or second or
sharpsburg or any of the rest of them
the winner was exhausted as a loser
whose battles absolutely exhausted both
sides one of them had barely enough
strength to crawl away the other didn't
have enough strength to follow up and
they said they didn't want him all
fighting after three days of gettysburg
uh i have never blamed mead for not
doing what lincoln expected he said we
had the enemy in our hand and mead
wouldn't close his hand made couldn't
close his hand it was too tired to close
his hand
[Music]
that war was so hard on the people who
fought it
just begin with a mini ball as it's
called
if you know a 50 caliber machine gun
bullet this is larger than a 50 caliber
machine gun bullet it's made of soft
lead when it hits bone it just scatters
bone all over hell and gone
it is a horrendous
weapon
and for men to stand up under that kind
of fire and then when
one side starts running they expect him
to be able to run after him is too much
the one as i said to start with was as
exhausted
as the loser after the battle was over
you mentioned gettysburg again
is my memory correct that you took jimmy
carter to gettysburg as a guide
let me yeah i took him he enjoyed it
very much what year
uh i've forgotten what year before or
after his presidency he was president at
the time he was we stayed at camp david
and when it went from there but he had a
very likable thing about he kept saying
where were the georgia troops where were
the georgia troops i like that in jimmy
carter how i mean that was before your
fame that brought it was brought about
by the ken burns series right how did
they find you to do that at that time
i guess because there was some sort of
respect for my three volume war which
had been written by then
how interested was he in the war very
much very much uh
he was interested in the first place
because he's georgian his people win it
uh
he
jimmy carter is such a likable person
anyhow
but his fondness for the civil war is
very attractive in him uh it's as if he
wants to understand america in part by
understanding the civil war
also the winston churchill back in the
early 1900s came over and went around
the battlefields do you ever study that
uh yeah i've studied what churchill's
had to say uh
he said the classic thing that's often
quoted he said it's the last of the old
romantic wars and the first of the new
wars all combined in one that's quite
true
the weapons
uh had outstripped the tactics that's
another reason the cashiers were so
heavy
uh
the tactics the napoleon fought by or
the british army up to that point had
been a muzzle loading musket
with an effective range of about 30
yards
so that
you weren't supposed to drop man at 200
yards with this rifle springfield which
you certainly could do a good marksman
could get all four rounds a minute
and believe me he knew how to shoot that
thing mesa arizona for shelby foote good
afternoon good afternoon
uh it's an honor to speak to you uh dr
foote
i have two grandfathers who fought
in the civil war
on the confederate side
one is r.s dooley
35th mississippi infantry
and the other one is
colonel hayes
of the uh of um
what's his name's calvary i've forgotten
i've i've had some success in tracing uh
the dually
but i haven't had much success in
tracing hayes
and he comes from up in northern
mississippi or just over the tennessee
line
what historical
source would you go to for something
like that
i would go to the mississippi department
of archives and history
uh they have a pretty full roster of all
the mississippians were in it but since
you're not sure which of the line he was
on or what unity was in that's a good
starting place find out what unit he was
in and then you'll be able to trace him
um which facility
uh
that's what you should do you should get
in touch
get his full name if you can
and his unit if you possibly can
and then they'll they'll take it from
there
oceanside california you're next
hello
mr foot
what a privilege c-span is allowing me
today
you know when you were narrating the uh
one of the sequences of burns's episodes
of the civil war
there were ladies in the room that said
if you were there they would just kiss
you to death
but what i really wanted to know
was
in one sequence you mentioned that there
was a general pemberton
and since that's in my line of heritage
i was curious about it as it was never
mentioned again except that he was sent
south
and i was just curious as if you if you
could give me any information
general pemberton was from pennsylvania
[Music]
he was an artilleryman originally
and was a lieutenant colonel when he
left the union arm and joined the
confederate army incidentally he had a
southern wife which is wheezed and he
went south he had two brothers who
stayed and fought with the north he was
in command of course at vicksburg doing
the siege and during the campaign
against grant
he was dependent on joe johnson coming
to his rescue which didn't happen
and pemberton is a very sympathetic
character to read about
a very likable man in many ways if
you're ever in vicksburg
you ought to
go away his headquarters was
and
[Music]
learn more about him and the more you
learn about it and more likable he gets
is it thai valley oklahoma yes
yes it is on the air
yes
go ahead please yes i'm calling from a
very small isolated community in
oklahoma southern oklahoma and i want to
thank mr foote for allowing us to see
his bedroom and i especially enjoyed his
comments on writers i also have a great
reader and i think it connects us to the
world thank you very much
thank you whenever we ask the questions
about writers people seem to like those
your story about the dip pen and five to
600 words a day and nobody edits you
have you ever run into anybody else that
has the same kind of thing you always
you can't make any rules whatever
speculations even about writers there's
differences chairs you know every writer
is different from that do you have
another writer that you've heard a story
about how he or she goes about writing
that you've always found interesting uh
there's a good contrast between wal
caprese and me
when i'm going to write a novel i write
a pretty full outline and i know exactly
how it's going to happen the actual
writing is comes clear walker never
makes an outline he said if i knew what
was going to happen unless next i
wouldn't be interested in in writing it
because that's not really true but it
it's partly true how about william
faulkner how did he write
nobody knows exactly how far they're
right faulkner only said that
[Music]
he said i don't write when hot weather
that's the only thing i've ever heard
from say you said earlier in the program
that you have one of the best
collections of faulkner books over here
on the day how do you know that and what
does that mean
because i'm familiar with the falcon
bibliography and there's nothing of any
big importance that i don't have over
there except the marble phone is first
book porn does any of those have
signatures on them yeah he signed the
hamnet for me
next call north little rock arkansas go
ahead please hi dr foots thank you so
much and i am truly enjoying this
program it's just so fascinating
i consider myself a little southern
belle and a very proud southerner in
every sense of the word and i've got a
couple of questions one of those is what
role did the women of the south play
during this horrendous civil war and
also um what what is your favorite part
your favorite event of the civil war
what would what represents everything
about the civil war thank you so much
there's no way i could sum up my my
favorite event
or single out anything but the women of
the south are a very interesting thing
uh
they had to survive something that that
people don't appreciate
the blockade was enormously effective in
in little ways
you couldn't get needles
for instance to sew with
you could get nails to hold your house
together
they were concentrating on getting
things like bullets and swords and guns
and things but these little things that
women wanted and meant so much to them
as they found out when they couldn't get
them anymore
that uh
they were indeed something put up with
it there was a northern soldier down
there
uh a northern captain his company went
through the place and they were running
around catching the chickens ringing
their necks
and plucking them and cooking them
and the mistress of the house who said
this is outraged why don't you stop this
and the man said
you you southern women
if it weren't for you the men would all
come home i know they can't come home
you wouldn't let them come home
and you want to sing the bonnie blue
flag and everything else and get so mad
if somebody gets your chickens
but you're killing our men and we're
killing your men
you you can stop worrying about chickens
we're going to eat them annandale
virginia you're on with foot
thank you for taking my call dr foote
i'm a big fan i have a
request for some observations this
summer i passed through fort riley
kansas and visited the cavalry museum
and saw a statue there
dedicated to the over 1 million horses
and mules that were lost during the
civil war i wonder if you could comment
on the
the difficulty of
providing support and logistics to both
armies
i have a second uh question i'd like
your opinion on something my uncle joe
was an officer with the 82nd airborne in
world war ii and he once told my father
that if he could
put together an ideal infantry unit it
would be southern boys and mexican boys
from the southwest he said they were
very tough he said they were
self-reliant and
usually could shoot and
didn't complain much about hardships i'd
appreciate your opinions on that thank
you
harvey hill another one of my favorite
confederate officers said that if he
could have an army that hit northern
artillery in southern infantry he would
have an army that the world has never
seen
uh
you get these these things i had an
interesting experience uh in the second
world war
i had command of some kids they were
really 18 19 years old and all from
mississippi and alabama
and a good friend of mine in the same
battalion had a company it was all new
york boys
and we said in the first 13 weeks of
training
and uh my boys had to memorize the
general orders the two or three of them
couldn't read let alone memorize so we
had this time his boys just zipped right
through that
then we had close all the drill and his
boys caught onto that real fast and mine
couldn't see much sense of this close
all the drill business so his battery
was much better than mine
in every measurable way
then we went into the field for our
first maneuver his all came down with
coals and god knows what else in mind
would have his locks out in the field
where they'd spent all their lives up
till then
but the interesting thing is after
they've all been in about three months
there wasn't a difference in the two
batteries his was just as good as mine
mine was just as good as he
that's the first thing that the army
does is they uh they make you a soldier
the marines do a superb job of it they
spend two or three weeks tearing you
down making you nothing
then spend two or three months making
you a marine
and it works it doesn't make any
difference where you came from on
november 17th you will be 85 years old
did you think you'd live that long
no i i i i like so many writers faulkner
for instance i thought i'd be dead by
40. certainly i couldn't imagine being
older than 40.
what do you
credit the success of living all this
long
medical science
really
yeah i'm talking about things like
stents
and aortic
thing everything all that sure
but at 85 you still smoke a pipe all day
right
i had this balloon thing in your heart
about 12 years ago
down at austin in new orleans and they
told me one thing i'd have to do is quit
smoking i'd been smoking cigarettes and
a pipe up to them and i said i would
give up cigarettes but i wasn't about to
kill my pipe it would be like giving up
my identity and they said well all right
if you have to
so i didn't smoke any more cigarettes
but i smoked my pipe three times as much
how many pipes do you think you have in
this room
oh i guess 50 or 60. people give them to
you some of them anybody we know give
you a pipe
uh
trying to think
nobody you know
dana point california you're on with
shelby foot go ahead please
yes dr foote um
like a comment you made earlier whenever
i'm reading about the civil war or my
some of my small uh excursions into the
south where i've looked at some of the
battlefields i get the
same anxiousness that you say you felt
uh standing at the bloody angle and i'm
curious
when
i read some of the battles and of course
i know the outcome ahead of time i have
that advantage
i get so anxious about the lack of
intelligence gathering and the ability
to get that intelligence to the officers
and then act upon that intelligence and
i wonder if you could uh comment
somewhat on on the hardships of getting
that intelligence to the officers and in
the case of gettysburg for instance uh
general lee didn't react to it and go
around the back thank you
uh you've touched on something very
important uh
whether it's true or not it's often said
that the weakest element in american
military is intelligence service the s2
is that most have to be the least
efficient class of
officer in in on the staff of the
regimental law division commander
the
the transmission of intelligence
is uh
is so difficult
we have an american
contempt for spying and tail telling and
all that
i think somewhat cripples up our ability
to function too well
uh
i can remember a time when someone like
john dillinger was a hero to the
american people and those scoundrels are
trying to kill him
it's all a very curious and somewhat
comical situation like that i don't
think uh earlier that did you deal with
the one million mules and horses earlier
with the question no i thought of that
and i'd forgotten it true story
horses are a tremendous problem
feeding them or feed a man you've got to
have two or three pounds of food a day
feed a horse you have to have something
like 15 pounds of food a day so that
getting that food up to the line is
quite a job
the horse situation
in the south
for the last year the war was crucial to
their being able for the cavalry to
function the north was superbly right uh
mounted
uh at that time but the south was
miserable tonight the horses were so
weak kneed they couldn't get up to a
gallop
there wasn't any bark left on any of the
trees in northern virginia because the
horses were eating it because they had
nothing else to eat it was a real
crippling thing that deserves more study
than it's had we have a little more than
20 minutes to go with shelby foot and
our three-hour in-depth program from
memphis here in his bedroom where he
wrote the last of the three-part series
the narrative on the civil war as we go
next to san antonio texas go ahead
please you're on the air good afternoon
so it's an honor to talk with you and
i'm just wondering uh were you aware
that uh that the battlefield at ridge
mountain had been preserved
and that to a very large extent that's a
result of the
ken burns television show and your
writing so congratulations on that
accomplishment
thank you did you know that
uh no i'm not sure what he means by rich
mountain
he's not there any longer so we won't
find out i don't know which rich
mountain you know about an hour ago
somebody called you dr foote and it just
kind of caught on and and if i remember
right you
just finished two years at the
university of north carolina but in the
wall in there you got a bunch of
honorary doctorate degrees you like the
sound of that dr foote i'm very
protective of my amateur standing and
i'm just barely a mister and i wish they
wouldn't call me doctor how many uh
honorary degrees do you have
eight or nine
one you have a favorite of all of them
no
no that wouldn't be fair
i guess if i had a favorite chapel ill
well i went to school for two years and
they gave me an honorary degree after i
was having and did people start calling
your doctor after that
i guess so but i'm not a doctor of
course an honorary degree doesn't make
you a doctor we're going to show your
doctorates in a moment we've got a
camera in the next room there on the
wall as we take a call from white plains
new york go ahead please uh yes i hope
i'm not asking a duplicate question but
many years ago and i haven't been able
to find it since i read a reference that
lee after the war was asked who was the
toughest general he faced and he said
mcclellan
to my surprise is that a myth
and did he ever tell anybody who he
thought was the toughest and who do you
think he might have thought
was the most difficult
he's quoted as saying someone asked him
who's the
most capable general he faced as an
opponent and he said this is direct
quote mcclellan by all odds
uh
some people have said that
mcclellan was his favorite general
because he beat him so regularly but lee
meant by that that mcclellan
did two things he was skillful in his
knowledge of the war
and he observed the rules of war
lee regretted very much that
civilians were interfered with in the
war he thought professional soldiers or
recruited soldiers ought to get out and
fight it out and they ought not bother
civilians a very old-fashioned notion
those of you who have just joined us we
haven't talked as much today as we have
in the past about shelby foote's
background his personal background but
those of you who are interested can go
on to booknotes.org and get the
transcript from our interview from about
eight years ago which goes into a lot of
detail about
dr foote's background let's go to
mitchell indiana next go ahead please
you're on the air
uh dr foote i always wanted to know
uh what color would the louisiana tiger
jacket be
what color would the louisiana tiger
jackets be i have absolutely no idea why
are you asking that caller
because uh
me and my uncle run a civil war shop in
mitchell indiana
and we're like getting the mannequin
ready
and it's gonna be a louisiana tiger
well louisiana tigers are something they
were a good unit they were mostly from
new orleans they were largely
uh italians and irishmen
uh
they were
they were a fighting unit all right but
i don't know what that they would be any
different from any other butternut or
gray uniform
when you hear that somebody has a
civil war shop in mitchell indiana does
that mean anything are there a lot of
those around the country
i think so but i don't have much to do
with them i i stay out of costumes and
mementos
again for those who've just
tuned in you've been in this house since
1966
how long have you been married to gwen
for 45 years come september she was your
third wife right
and
what role has she played over the years
a tremendous role she's been the
sustainer of my continuing to do this
work without gwen to look after me i
don't know how they've gotten it done
well you know you read though a lot that
some writers
their spouses
edit their spouses read the manuscripts
yeah does she do any of that no no
you see movies about writers or pianists
or something a little wife comes in
comforts them helps them with their work
what you tell is get out and let me
alone i'm busy
while you're working
but
gwen knows that uh
it doesn't come any news to her that i'm
i like to be left alone while i'm
writing but during those years when you
would spend as you said maybe two months
in here
day after day or after you know the
whole day what was your relationship
with your wife during that period well
it didn't keep me from sitting down and
having a couple of good drinks of
whiskey soon his work was over we had a
life you know a social life and a life
with each other
uh like anybody else it's just like i
worked perhaps longer hours than most
husbands and i'm around the house which
is very hard on a wife to have the
husband around all the time but that's
the condition when you're married to a
writer you have
the fellows put up with all day long
alexandria virginia you're next go ahead
please yeah hi um i was interested in
your comments on
vietnam and also on the amputees i was
101st
airborne in vietnam and i lost both my
legs
and i think one of the things with
vietnam is all the people came from
different places and they left at
different times so it sort of
interfered somewhat with the camaraderie
but the question i called for uh was in
terms of reparations you had talked
about the number of people who had
lost their lives in the war and and to
me that seemed like a pretty high price
it is i don't think there's any question
of reparations though they didn't have
the standard ten thousand dollar life
insurance policy they had when i was in
the army god knows what it is now
when i was in the army a recruit made
twenty one dollars a month
and after he'd been in for three months
he made thirty dollars a month
but now they get paid noble noble
amounts of sound to me noble
uh
i i don't i really don't know
when you write it
what
about the length of the sentence
do you have a philosophy of that
very much so um
sentences should vary in length you have
a long rambling sentence then boom the
short jokes in the long run shorthand
and three short jolts
all that is very important in writing
and you may not be aware that it's going
on and it's best you not be aware of it
but it has its effect
uh
a pristine sentence that wanders and
weaves all over the place can
can could be a beautiful thing
now we talked at the beginning that
you've read
remembrance of things passed by marcel
cruz nine times at least
but you have over here on the wall a
photograph of him or a picture of some
kind and i don't mean to be
offend you but that is not a very
nice uh frame that you've got around
here you've got a couple of pieces of uh
it's supposed to my son sent it to me
from paris how long has that been up
there that's been up there about 10
years
uh
it's uh
it's taken from uh
it's sort of tilted to balance that
little white thing in the lower
uh quadrant or
the second quadrant layer
that's the top of a couch and it really
should be this way he has his head way
on the side but they straightened him up
but that's very good picture of him do
you think you would have liked him uh i
know i would have liked him everybody
liked it what are you doing 1924 he died
in
1922 22 yeah same time as my father and
he died
the day before
my sixth birthday what
who who introduced you to him
uh my mother i i introduced me to him i
got a random house catalogue saying he
was having this new four volume
additional proofs and i had read about
proof somewhere and i got my mother to
give it to me for my 17th birthday it
came there about a month before my 17th
birthday and by my 17th birthday i had
read it the first time now what's over
here on your shelf here in your bedroom
was purchased when
by and
well how long have you owned that if
you're talking about that four volume
four volume i got that in 1934
and uh
the five volume one up here
i got two years ago from the modern
library there's a three volume proofs
that i don't much like
uh
it's a re-translation i don't like the
new translation as well as the old
it is the old but they polished it up
but they call themselves polishing it up
edina minnesota you're on with shelby
foot hello oh thank you mr lamb uh mr
foote uh i have an observation and then
a question or two and
my observation may be misguided but i
hope you will at least comment on it for
me
i don't see you
so much as an historian as i see you as
a storyteller
i don't see you so much as in the
tradition of gibbon as in perhaps the
tradition of homer
and that may betray my own prejudice as
maybe a literary person who loves
history
but
two reasons have led me to that and and
i've taught it that way uh first your
your book is not titled history it's
titled the narrative
and then uh secondly i i see this
wonderful clarity
of vision that you have about these
heroic characters in an epic story
and like homer you're able to treat them
with a wonderful balance and
appreciation of the great human
qualities rather than the northern or
southern qualities a sense of what it
means to be a human being so that
when achilles meets hector
homer doesn't distinguish between the
nobility of the two they both have
greatness of character so i wonder in my
questions if you might comment on your
feelings about homer and
whether you feel any influence there
and then a couple of other questions uh
one i i don't allow my students at least
to bring to
class the time life series which is a
beautifully produced series and
makes a wonderful historical book with
its uh illustrations in those 14 volumes
but
i only allow them the
uh the written word i don't want them
distracted by photographs and uh other
things uh because it would be like
illustrating homer with all kinds of
greek shields and so forth you are
detracting from the poetry
and i believe you are a poet i i hope
you'll allow me to say so i think your
uh your words and your love for the
language uh and for shakespeare and
proofs indicate your uh your great
poetic talents and then finally if
there's time and i apologize for going
on so long but
um i've been a a reader of walker percy
from his first novel when i was
i guess maybe in college in 1960 or 61.
and i i've sensed a great uh influence
of religion and not specifically
um religion in the sense of
creeds but of the great metaphysical
philosophical questions in his work i
wonder if you feel uh that there has
been an influence
of religion and philosophy in your work
and if that's too personal a question i
apologize for asking it and please
ignore it but if you can among the other
things answer those
and uh thank you very much for the
opportunity to ask this question to you
and mr land thanks
thank let's go back to the beginning he
said you're a storyteller you like that
i i thank you for the compliment uh
especially for the mention of homer
uh in the first or second volume
uh
i expressed my debt to the indian
the idiot was my model
uh and it's very perceptive for you to
have
have seen that not many people have seen
it
uh i don't think anybody's written
better narrative
than than homer wrote especially in the
t e shaw translation
the lattimore i like very much but the
short translation i like
of the odyssey
i wish he'd live to translate the idiot
but the the
lattimore translation of the idiot is
practically a bible with me we've been
talking about my reading of proof
i've read the the lattimore translation
of the idiot
nearly as often as i have the proofs and
uh i quite consciously took the idiot as
a model
in writing uh
this this civil war history now right
above you right above that uh
that that fluorescent lamp that you've
had for
all your life yes
several it looks like the holy bible
three it looks like three copies that's
yeah that's the three volume bible three
volume bible and there's another bible
what role has religion played in your
life
uh not much
uh i love the bible
but i i have never felt any pull toward
religion and perhaps a shameful thing to
say
but
[Music]
i'll just go really crazy and say my
life is art
rather than religion
in other words art is my religion
and
that's a bad thing to say in many ways
and i certainly don't want anybody to
model themselves after me in that regard
but i just never have felt
the need for a deep religious thing it
may come
and in your
in your time with walker percy over
those 60 years you used to jab him a
little bit about his catholicism
was he a convert
he was a convert and and uh
as enthusiastic as most converts are
especially at the start
and i used to guy him about it some he
put up with it pretty well el paso texas
for shelby foot
couple minutes left go ahead please
yes a few years ago i went through the
vicksburg vicksburg war memorial
and i noticed
units from
missouri on both sides
and
and there was a comment made earlier
about missouri and i wondered if uh mr
foote could uh tell us what he knows
about uh the state of missouri
in the civil war
that's a pretty big subject called call
on far but missouri uh
was fighting civil war before anybody
else was fighting the civil war the
kansas border wars were going on it was
it was savage bloody business
uh missouri incidentally i've been
talking about bedford forest all along
uh joe shelby was a one hell of a
cavalry commander himself
the war in missouri is intensely
interesting to read there hadn't been
enough done about it there ought to be a
lot more
san francisco for shelby foot hello
yes sir how you doing i have um recently
had the privilege of writing a research
paper about uh general nathan bedford
forrest i found his tactical
contributions to be amazing in numerous
campaigns
do you feel that his connection with
fort pillow
and
after the war's connection with or
involvement with the clue initially with
the ku klux klan dampened his legacy
and
perhaps he's not as appreciated as the
soldiers he should be today thank you
there's no doubt about it those two
factors have made many people see forest
as the villain of the civil war
they should understand a lot better
about things
fort pillar for instance he was forced
to stop the killing
not caused it
he's the one who stopped it made his
soldiers stop killing those people and
they were killing them there's no doubt
about it and he had sent a note ahead of
time saying sorrendo i won't accept the
consequences he always sent such notes
into demanding who surrender
fort pillar is an unhappy thing but
forest certainly cannot be blamed for
it's a good instance i can prove that
lincoln heard about fort pilla and he
wrote the grant and said i want this
thing thoroughly looked into
and examined and somebody being brought
to justice for it granted turned it over
to sherman who made his investigation
and made no recommendation at all if you
know anything about sherman if he had
thought for the forest had anything to
do with smaller than those people he
would have immediately insisted on
something being done about and he did
not
can you remember in your 85 years where
you had the best moment
no
i i i i
i don't i don't deal in best sources
biggest accomplishment
most enjoyable yeah the day i finished
the war you could call such a time
are you happy you're sitting at that
desk writing or doing something else let
me tell you what true happiness is in in
this world i know what it is
it's when you go to bed at night and put
your head on that pillow
looking forward to getting up next
morning to get to this desk that is
happiness that is true happiness
chandler arizona for shelby foot go
ahead please yes good afternoon i think
c-span and book notes for having mr foot
on your show i've been long waiting uh
since this show was first announced mr
foote i i simply love to listen to you
speak
from the days of
ken burns series on the civil war
through today's show you remind me so
much of listening to my grandfather talk
when i was a young
young boy the stories that he used to
tell me
two questions number one
knowing that i love to listen to you
speak have you ever put your
voice narratively of your books onto
audio cassette
and secondly i know it's like asking a
father with five children to pick his
best but do you have one of your books
that you that is closest to your heart
or that you enjoy the most and i'll hang
up and listen to your response thank you
let me take those in order
the modern library has
cassettes
of me reading two sections from the
civil war one is called
the beleaguered city about the vicksburg
campaign
the other one is called uh stars and
their courses about the gettysburg
campaign they're both about 300 page
books and they take about i don't know
nine or ten cassettes
uh
you can get those at any bookstore
and what was the last thing
your favorite oh i i i i don't i don't
watch uh
i will tell you one thing on tuesday
another thing on thursday so it's just
will not tell you anything about
favorites have you read a book recently
that's new that you would
that you enjoyed
yeah let me think what it was something
i enjoyed a lot
damn all
right
i've been made reading james merrill's
poetry lately which i had neglected all
this time and he's a wonderful poet i
think he's our point of the second half
of the 20th century the way i think
about john crow ransom for the first
half of the twenties one of the things i
notice you say a lot is he's as happy as
a cult and clover right do you remember
when you first heard that why you use it
i think it was saying all the time i was
talking about when i got and learned got
to reading and
discovered literature i was happy as a
colton clover right coolville ohio
you're next oh first i would like to
thank you for letting us into your home
and answering our questions today and i
had just one question i hope it's on a
repeat uh as much uh joy as frankly i've
gotten out of reading your narrative
i've probably enjoyed the uh narration
of stars and the courses as much and i
was wondering if you had any plans on
doing additional narrations of any of
your work
as i said a minute ago there's the
beleaguered city which is the vicksburg
campaign it's of the same length in fact
it's because that's longer than stars
and its courses but i don't have any
plans for myself
uh reading any more of it
the whole thing is in blackstone
and then books on tape
and it's a huge number of cassettes but
they both they both have it for anybody
who wants to listen to it in an
automobile or something for shelby foot
louisville kentucky hello yes um i've
been a great admirer also i think you're
one of our national treasures but i'm
also
a amateur historian on the civil war
born in ohio but raised in the south i
have in my possession seven treasured
letters from a great grandfather our
great grand great great grandfather
i have two in my hand one written
near a port mcallister on december 25th
1864 which he mentioned sherman and
they're moving on from savannah to uh
the next city i forget which um and
they're just they're very they're
treasures and and they've been passed
down to me
and i think they ought to be someplace
other than in my desk wanted your advice
if you held such letters that you know
name specific locations and generals and
so forth what would you do with
them the first thing you should do is
take them to a real good
reproducer
get get them
get good copies made of them you can go
to
many of these places you make good
copies and get that and that secures the
safety from losing them entirely
uh then the original or a copy ought to
be in your
department of archives and history and
whatever states you're in those things
are very important sometimes little
things in them that seem to matter
not at all are very important to
historians it might determine where
stonewall jackson was at a certain time
of day during an important day in his
life so
all those things ought to be kept
many of them are
saying for goodness sake send me a
blanket i'm freezing to death and things
like that but there are surprisingly
interesting things to be gotten out of
those letters too
we're about to take our last call and i
think you'll agree that our callers
today have been
superb
yeah 56 calls from people who all were
serious about this subject and serious
about
what you've done in your life let's go
to dayton daytona florida for our last
call
hello daytona beach you're on the air
yeah thank you mr foot what an
extraordinary day this has been thank
you very much um
i'm calling on behalf of my wife who has
a question for you and that is
her great great grandfather was
claiborne fox jackson of missouri
and she'd like to know more about the
circumstances if you know about them for
his moving the government from missouri
to marshall texas during the war when he
was the governor of missouri
and do you know if indeed his son was
also governor thanks again
i don't know whether his son was
governor or not the the removal
uh
was progressive at first he had to
get out of missouri into arkansas then
he had to get out of arkansas into texas
as the union forces advanced on him
he was he was a very effective good
governor so
your wife can be proud of
of dissent from him
[Music]
i don't think there's been a biography
of him but he's often mentioned in
anything concerning the
trans-mississippi trouble is that
trans-mississippi has been woefully
neglected in history of the war
what's going on in missouri and arkansas
and also in that part of louisiana
that's over that way uh
was enormously important and should be
studied far more than it has been
the career of kirby smith who was in
command of the trans-mississippi is a
very interesting one uh
so there ought to be a lot more study
about the trans mississippi thanks also
to jim and clark for all his work from
for c-span and this project we'll close
on this
email
as a way kind of thanking your wife gwen
for allowing us to come into this place
and it's from nelly rook
and she writes dear sir it's a pleasure
to see you on c-span my mother and i
were on the delta queen in the early 90s
and we had the pleasure of meeting you
and your wife here's her last comment
and i want you to comment on it what a
lovely voice she has
all i could do is agree with that right
people always talk about
southern voices in mississippi delta and
memphis forces it all comes out of i
haven't had what we call colored nurses
when we've grown up we get this from the
blacks that's where this is where it all
comes from practically everything we got
i some point in my life by the time i
was 21 years old i realized that every
morsel of food i'd ever eaten every
piece of fabric i ever had on my back
every hour of education came out of
black labor
it was all that when i was growing up
and
there was a woman who raised me named
natalie lloyd she met mother maiden my
mother all my aunts and uncles put
together
it's all the black experience and i go
down to the delta today
and it just it breaks my heart to see it
it's like the place isn't there anymore
because all the blacks have left and
that's what the delta was i was raised
in a in a black society really they
weren't running it but they were doing
it
thank you shelbyfoot
tonight on book tv's in-depth series
shelby foote
writer playwright and civil war
historian mr foot has been a three-time
guggenheim fellow lecturer at the
university of virginia and memphis state
he is author of stars in their courses
shiloh and the civil war a narrative
among others you can see our interview
with mr foote at his home in